how many submissions is Holi shorts
received each of the past five years
yeah so in the five years ago we were at
around 2000 or so submissions for that
year this past year we received 5,000
submissions so we've in between that
we've gone from 2,000 to 5,000 for the
last five years increased around 500 or
so each of those years so 2,000 2,500
3,000 3,500
so on so forth tune our last year we're
at five thousand submissions for
fourteenth year this is our 15th year
coming up and we're expecting
potentially six thousand submissions
that's a big increase and we might jump
up a thousand this year based on
averages of course our early bird
deadline is coming up next Friday so you
know we're estimating what it could be
so yeah it's a seen a big jump these
last five years definitely very cool of
those multi thousand plus films that
you've received since the inception of
Holly shorts how many would you say
you've personally watched a lot I say it
used to be hundred percent now it's not
as possible with Monica films and a lot
family and new duties and things on top
of that it's probably a good idea at
least 80% of all the films Wow
I've not even more I mean there's just
the last few years we've grown a review
team where I'm overseeing the process
more now and watching certain scores and
rewatching some films and watching my
own but I'm not just hands down watching
everything like it was before say five
years ago where I was literally just
hunkered down watch every single film
2000 films is much easier than watching
five to six thousand naturally just time
permitting right so I'd say that's
probably a healthy and safe number
because I'm I like to I like to see
everything as much as I can possibly do
you know it's just it's a personal sense
of pride and also maybe we may be able
to beat rolling iron or make sure I'm
always yeah so so there's that part of
it and of course at the end films that
I'm of course watching in or their
people are watching and reviewing this
course I'm gonna program the films that
program the festival so in the end the
films that do get in I'm watching all of
them so of that number you asked if you
look at the number of the films are
accepted or in the festival those that
watch hundred percent off so naturally
so yeah
I'm gonna review scores of other judges
and say okay I want to watch these these
these I'm gonna make sure let's see what
they're talking about here and kind of
just double-check their work and if I
like the films and I can sort of makes
that sort of passive approval I'll be
the one to program the film so you know
I'm sort of I guess the latus go around
if it gets it or not kind of thing I'm
curious about this review team who are
they and how do you screen them to know
that they're really indie film fans well
we do a process of sort of give them a
soft start right like okay hey you know
this is our criteria this is what we
look for we have a very big breakdown
very thorough breakdown of how we judge
how we score what we're looking for what
the process is understanding how many
films come in because you know if you if
you just watch films for for the film
right if you just watching a film you
might like a film you know and you think
it's okay and there's there's elements
you like those element you don't like
well you're like oh well this this has a
chance or something you might score
maybe a little lenient or something not
understanding that there are six
thousands submissions and is only formed
in spots that actually can get in so
that number is what five five to eight
percent can actually make the festival
it's very competitive so if you're
looking at it from that standpoint and
only watch five to ten films they may
not understand the full scope of how
many films are there does that make
sense like there's a lot of films to
watch so if they're just looking at
their batch they may not understand the
full scope so we try to break down very
thorough
you know like listed on email of what
we're looking for what the scope of how
many films we receive what kind of films
we've have received looking at the
lineups from the years past we share the
lineups hey look at these review our
schedules so you understand what we've
shown what kind of films we show the
genres styles different things you know
so they understand when they're looking
at the films like okay what is the full
scope of how the festival programs and
what we've had before what we're looking
for and things like that so we give them
all that and and again assign only a few
films to start if we love their results
and then feel it's on par with what
we're looking for then we'll keep them
on board to review many more films and
you know I know oversee the process if
it's just - if usually - lean is more of
troubling for me personally honestly we
do it is a very competitive festival and
obviously we don't want someone who's
just every film is obviously a home run
and it's amazing and you watch the film
and it's not on par
that's not what we're looking for now
all the same time if you're too harsh
it's also you know something it could be
a fantastic film and they're grading it
like a three out of ten and it's like
okay you're you're being you know
unreasonable so there's both sides you
don't want that and if that's the case
then we just sort of you know sometimes
we let them know hey we just moving on
or some people just you know quite
honestly we just you know move on or no
respond like all right you know we're
going in the direction we just kind of
like you know look for other people and
things like that but yeah that's that's
basically the sort of process if we like
what their early work is with a few
films then we can keep them on for more
if the people that you know in the film
industry
is there anyone that's watched as many
short films as you have you went to you
um I don't know you know I would say
probably no I think now at this time now
like we talked about this years ago I'd
say who knows I don't know I think it's
safe to say you know and you look at the
math of all the films over all this many
years and since we're just shorts
actually Schwartz only and not the
features I think we've probably watched
as many shorts as anyone in the world I
guess a lot of movies you watch so start
thinking like yeah have I watched more
shorts and anyone I don't know it sounds
weird to say but it's possible I think I
don't know it's a lot of films I mean
you're talking at least I mean it's say
on average 15 years average is
twenty-five hundred films let's just say
what is that number that's 2,000 should
have 30,000 movies or so I don't know
it's a lot of movies so we've seen a lot
of shorts yeah so yeah I think we asked
you this before Dan but why is it so
important for you to play such a vital
role in the submission process I mean
why not have an intern do all of it
yeah well you know it still goes back to
the same thing we've talked about before
is that it's our name on this of course
that's probably was not my personal name
but the filmmakers know you know they
know soul Theo demonical Castro they
know the team behind the fest
it's me take pride in that so it's it's
always a challenge of yes we obviously
need help in certain areas and I just
that's not one of them where I feel like
it's it's something we want to just
completely pass on and say we're not
gonna be that that involved as far as
programming or watching the films we
want to know what the
who was making them you know if we enjoy
them we think they're for our taste
every festival has their films not every
films for every festival it's that's a
she a line from John Gant I stole that
line making sure he gets credit John
you're watching that's your line you
know and it's but it's very true I've
always felt that he said it at panels or
a festival it's very true it's not we
like certain films some festivals may
not like we've had films there Oscar
qualifying now that they're from our
festival that one or festival and then
they don't get big a projective other
festivals so it could be that even that
that varying right where a film can make
you know the Oscars and still get
rejected by festivals so you know not
not in that said like we want to make
sure that sort of our tastes and our
feeling and vibe of the films and we
sort of give our simple approval of
these films is this it's still something
we control and you know it's ours so we
take pride in that so it's just
important to still take part in that
very heavily and not just say hey well
let's just pass on to all these people
and this have interns just watch films
and and then you know we'll just kind of
like let them essentially handle that
process I don't want isn't I don't want
us to really get into get into that now
if we had you know got to a point when
it was you know overwhelming and it was
just 12,000 plus emissions or something
in it then we really got to really
really but we're growing and it's
getting there but we're not there yet
and you know I don't know what cap off
will have its emissions or when it will
peak out but you know 4-cyl the future
we still want to stay heavily involved
net would you say you're addicted to
short films I guess pretty good yeah I
mean I I guess now yeah I think so maybe
I think early on it was more of the love
of film and filmmaking and being
involved with the festival involved in
industry in the process it was something
we were excited about but now it's a
yeah I mean as many films have washed
over these years
as we've all watched and and and it's
the process of discussing shorts and you
know what they're places in this sort of
hierarchy the industry with the new age
of streaming and everything what does
that mean for us and for shorts we want
to champion shorts and we spend a lot of
our time watching short films I spend a
heavy majority of my time outside of
anything else I do as a hobby
outside of
and watching the films is watching short
films oh I guess with the controlling
aspect of what we've been outlying home
saying what I want to give up control
and not watching homes anymore
I guess you're getting it's fair to say
that I guess for the Schwartz you know I
think it's a it's a haven't thought of
that way but it is actually it makes a
lot of sense and I don't think that's a
bad thing I don't want control over you
know putting I know it's not and you're
too personal or three personal names on
it but that you know your that's your
brand and so that makes sense yeah it's
when people if someone's buying a ticket
to attend the festival you know they are
it's a representation of what we're
programming what we chosen based on all
the pool submissions obviously where
we're taking of what was what came to us
if we had five films submitted and
that's all we had and we're picking from
five films okay but we have this many
thousands of films we're picking from
this pool and you know we take pride in
what that ends up being what reflects on
screen it's very exciting to showcase
what we feel are the next gen filmmakers
or filmmakers are on the rise or just
extremely talented or just
thought-provoking or unique and showing
those voices and giving them a chance to
screen and it's it's at our event it's
exciting it's something we obviously
that's what we're doing it's what it's
for you know if you didn't like that
then then what are we even doing this
for so it's a yeah it's something that
we're you know of course gonna be very
proud you know they're very proud about
so yeah yeah I think um yeah missus says
it's something that you know it's very
important for us you said next gen do
you see a difference in style or
approach across the generation so let's
say when you first started in the 30
seat theater that I remember that one
theater that I went to and it was great
it was a lot of fun even for 30 people
but that was 15 years ago
so maybe Gen Xers were submitting then
then you have Millennials and now gen Z
do you see a difference in their
filmmaking well yeah yeah there is
because just think of the time frame of
what your capabilities were right I mean
back then 50 years ago there was no
YouTube there was no nothing streaming
was really not a thing yet it was it was
there was maybe at the time there was
might have been maybe I film I think was
like the first site doing any streaming
or anything where you could post video
it was like I think that was basically
about it
and that might even not even been the
first year might have been like your two
or three maybe then 15 years not a
little little fuzzy on the exact dates
and details but you know so so the
creation of content what you're doing
your goal for making your films back
then was more thesis films I got a ton
of student films thesis films it was
more of that you didn't see as much of
the the genre films right like now we're
seeing all these amazing visual effects
and sci-fi films and sci-fi shorts was
not something that wasn't something we
were they were seeing back then but now
because of whether it's different
technologies different use of different
cameras that the the accessibility of
visual effects and learning these things
filmmakers are looking to post things on
their own channels or maybe they have
subscribers or then you have the younger
generation of the Millennials who you
know are into web serie stuff and love
web series and shows and and all that so
that all is something that the website
is did the word anything exist back then
there was no such thing as a what is a
web series there was no such thing 50
years ago now web series and web content
and YouTube read all this that this is a
this is a real thing this is where many
many shows and the craters are making
stuff constant all time I mean there's a
whole weekend of I mean there's plenty
of festivals I just do web stuff we have
a web series category you can have your
own web series festival a standalone
there's not much content out there so
that's where we've seen a big change and
kind of the added genres and the
different styles of filmmaking and of
course categories like web series which
just didn't exist we started this so
literally use adapt as we've gone along
we added that category probably I think
six or seven years into the festival
maybe you know before that there was
just it wasn't something we were even
you know gonna do so and we just started
we're like this is something even worth
adding and that kind of thing so we've
seen how that's changed this sort of
short short content narrative what about
issue-driven do you think 15 years ago
we were submitting as many shorts that
were about specific issues and things
that people are trying to solve it has
that always been a part of filmmaking or
do you think it's more so now with this
new generation I also think I think more
so I think more so yeah I think I mean
yeah it's always part of filmmaking
especially of course documentary subject
I mean your short short Doc's are always
going to tackle certain subjects you
know whether it's political
controversies or whatever you know all
that stuff that's normal but sets we've
seen that even
many years ago but now let me just even
this these last few years and you know
with of course political climate right
now and Trump we've seen as little films
as being made about him and about that
the the instability of things that go on
and then how fast you can create the
content to submit right like they can
make a film a filmmaker can make a film
no not talking quality production budget
whatever you can make it in a matter of
dates a day and and have it cut and
submit it I mean in a matter of days you
could actually submit that now again not
talking quality or if it's good or not
or whatever but the the submission comes
in so the film can be made and submitted
that fast so there is a sort of what's
happening now can can be seen in the
reflection of the submissions each year
whether it's political stuff now or I
think I'll say five years ago what was
some of the you know just just I guess
long story short basically what you're
seeing happen in a climate of the world
we're seeing come through our way you
know much much faster and it just sort
of like you're seeing the wave of how
people think it's kind of a cool thing
like the process of what's coming our
way is based on filmmakers in the world
what they're making based on what's
happening and that wasn't so much the
cases early on not to say that wasn't
happening but the accessibility of the
filmmaking process and how fast it's
it's become as far as the shorts content
shorts films be made it's changed so
maybe that's just a product of that but
you see more and more of that and back
then we didn't see as much it was a
thesis film took more time to make and
there's planning and so you see just
some student films and stuff shot on
film so that's obviously also a slower
process so it's different there's just
different you know yeah I mean that said
also we only did receive you know first
year we're stalking 23 movies second
year 170 years so you know different
amount of films but I mean quickly we're
up to around almost a thousand in a few
years and then so you're still getting a
gauge of what's out there do you think
short films get the respect that they
deserve
I think I think more so now I think it's
getting there I think for us the dream
or the goal is that it becomes
the basically the norm right like
there's more of a social norm to short
films for filmmaking the content
creation and also the viewership you
know people are going to turn into want
to watch shorts in a way that is has
changed and never been done before you
know if you know what I'm saying like
like right now you think of a course
feature films theatrical right you think
okay big films you know I want to go to
see the scene one movie and that's
that's the the story in the draw like
you know who's what movies out there you
know who's starring in and all that kind
of stuff and of course now there's also
a turn to that because now Netflix and
streaming has changed how they released
stuff now you're gonna have gotta go see
this movie a bird box everyone's talking
about bird box social chatter about this
thing it's a movie that is just on
Netflix so it's a streaming movie that's
a feature but I think that shift can now
go towards and help the short film cause
I think people can look to short content
in short films in a way that's never
been done before it's something that
we're working on behind the scenes is
something we're thinking it could be the
future the younger generation they grew
up watching stuff on their tablets
phones short content you know that's
been something they're used to you know
they didn't grow up watching TV the same
way we did where it was okay you got a
tune in this day this time to watch your
favorite show TGIF on ABC all that
doesn't really exist anymore in the same
way and so all of that I think in lends
itself towards people wanting to
actually watch short films and seem
really cool short films and you see the
viewer numbers in some of these films
and stuff that's whether it's on Vimeo
whether it's on platforms whether it's a
dust or you know the viewership is
there's millions of using some of these
films so people are watching so the
question now becomes who's watching who
are the viewership who are the
viewership of these films and how do you
turn that into a sort of commercial
viable thing that's not just that like a
niche but something that's commercial
and more likely universally except there
are known so it's more household so
that's the next step and I think we're
definitely more so there than we were
before
definitely we started this 15 years ago
it was not it was thought of as just the
little niche things short film student
film theses are creative very artistic
and you know that it was like a
different thought process to what meant
to CSU or film and and also you see with
the oscar-nominated films in the no
theatrical release every year they've
done better and better than theatrical
release every year and last like six six
years or so
you see the numbers the box offices
they're just performing because you know
there's limited release but in that
release there they're making good money
and people want to see him so they're
going out to the theater to see the
films whereas early on it was you
thought and years ago I wouldn't happen
or who's gonna go see these movies right
and you know there was a sort of
negative thing to that and I think now
that's gone away so yeah I think there's
a there's a thing's a bright future
future so bright I gotta wear shades oh
my 80s reference yeah do you think
though that hardcore feature film
proponents have changed their tune about
making sure she because there's those
two schools of thought and and people
have you know pretty legitimate reasons
for either either case but do you think
they've they've switched in terms of
some of these hardcore feature film like
only have actually said you know what
now is the time actually to dabble in
that and it does make sense to make sure
it's yeah I think so I think so I think
I mean you're seeing we even seen some
of the films that we received that our
directors that we know of at times where
the you know whether it's notoriety or
they're known for their future work
they're making sure it's various reasons
whether they want to experiment a
certain type of story they just really
want to try to tell us one story they
want to make it short to showcase what
they can do with that story for a
feature there's different reasons what
people do make sure it's not always just
about that story or narrative sometimes
it is a teaser for a feature and this
kind of thing you see that sometimes but
we're seeing there's the crossover of
both it's not just short film that is
making shorts and it's just short
content that's all they do of course
they may go on to do features or shows
and all that stuff but there's also a
feature filmmakers or people who are
established in that way or doing
features that are also doing shorts so
you know it's sort of back and forth I
don't know if it's a you know some kind
of wave or it's just like it's just
gonna change things or if that's gonna
I'm not sure about all that like that's
a bigger question you know but I think
of all this I think the one area that is
changed stuff is this capability of the
the platforms are spending money people
are spending money right Apple and
Netflix in Amazon to create content that
can be shorter where that really falls
under is a lot of times as TV TV now has
changed everything and there's that's
not what it used to be it's it's this
big Wild West of unknown there's tons of
money going into shows people why
shows I would think probably like never
before and we're seeing a lot of our
creators that have gone on to now go on
and do TV shows you know whether they
create their own the alumni have gone
and do some stuff in there doing TV
shows I think like more like never
before I mean just seeing following some
of our alums and then see what shows
they either she'll run and create or
just the directing stuff there's just
there's a lot more work there and
there's just it's all for is a different
kind of creative freedom and and you're
seeing that I guess that turn of like
shorts to TV as well so you know it's
definitely a different time and you know
and then TV is definitely an area where
you're seeing a lot of a lot of our
short filmmakers kind of go on to do
know TV so we see every year whether
it's Twitter or somewhere on social
media that Holly Schwartz has always
designated one of the top festivals
worth the entry fee what does that mean
to you well it's it's it's very
important I mean love doesn't it's it's
obviously an article distinction someone
saying that and writing an article about
it so it's not something we obviously
had control over very proud of that and
happy about it and it's not like any
kind of make a break thing but it is it
is something that we take pride in we
want people to feel like they submit to
the festival it's it's gonna be worth
their time and money now obviously again
you submit you may not get in if you
don't get in it in that sense I suppose
for it may not be worth it to set person
and in some sense but there are other
opportunities with their monthly
screenings and things like that where
we're not just taking the film's to the
festival and that's it there's when you
get in the festival there's a lot that
comes with that but if you don't get in
but you're also invited to the monkey
screening or we don't quite when I able
to quite program to film the festival
but we can showcase it in a different
month you're still getting something out
of your submission is still very
valuable so that's something we offer
that some festivals do not offer don't
do because they don't have them of the
events so we feel that there's there's a
lot of value there and it's something of
us we take pride in we're not you know
here to just you know you know you guys
take people's submissions and money and
just like not watch the movies or
something that's not what we're doing so
it's obviously it's very important for
us to feel like it's worth people as
well to submit and when they do get in I
think there's a I think it's a huge
value I mean you spend whether it's
thirty five bucks or seventy whatever
the top and you know low end to top end
as far as early bird late deadline all
that that money is if you accept it is
extremely well spent I mean you know
you're gonna get passed as the first
what you passed itself you get one all
access badge 600 bucks you that's
already value in itself to have a pass
you and your guests or other or that's
producer director team or whatever it
get passes those badges get you in all
the parties screenings everything so
you're able to access everyone and be at
the festive one attend and take part of
all that so that right there is already
great then you have an awesome screening
and a great venue of the Chinese Theater
so it's good quality screening great
sound great screen quality the DCP looks
great everything's good so now you're
getting an awesome experience there with
a great crowd so that's part of it
that's great then of course the parties
are networking very valuable and that's
I think probably the biggest value of
anything if you had a festival you have
to be a part of it
to take part to meet people share your
stories and ideas talk about your film
Lee someone just saw if they just saw
your film you're not there to talk about
it
hey where's that director that I love
that movie oh no they're not there ok
well the person just forgets it's like
they move on like where they can't talk
to you maybe they don't know how to get
a hold of you like well then that's an
opportunity lost it and mingle with
someone to network to collaborate what
if it's a agent or someone who can sign
you whatever it's a producer who's
interested in your work and wants to see
more wants to produce you you know you
don't know so we've stories of a bound
of people after the fact of emailed us
and hey I met this person the festival
and I worked with them on this and this
happened because of this or you know I
got booked on commercials and got my
career at this point because of that
screening and that experience and being
there talking to people there and they
loved my movie that's what it's all
about that's that's that's just that's
cold so when that happens that's
exciting and that's what we would take
pride in and if you're not there for
that you miss it out but I think is a
huge value in that so definitely it's
something that's for us is again we talk
about the pride of the name and people
know it's us and you know we obviously
want this thing to be a great event
you know we took a lot of pride in that
so definitely it's a it means a lot
you've always enjoyed the q and A's
after you know I went to one of the
monthly screenings a few months ago and
the QA was just just because I was so
curious about the stories behind it so I
think it's so valuable for people to
attend if they can you know that's OU's
that lets you get the QA people can hear
you share your stories and yet and have
an audience of people that have that you
have they're here they want to know and
hear from you in that moment that's your
time sort of shine not everyone some
people love ik you nation people are
very nervous and shy about it they don't
like talking from the crowds but hey
it's a chance to get up and do it
overcome that
and share your stories whatever want to
talk about your reasoning for making
your movies that's a cool experience I
mean at that moment that crowd of how
many people 100 200 400 500 they're
there they listen to you talk about your
project and they're giving you the love
they want to hear what you have to say
about that's you know you got everyone's
attention that's really cool and that's
that's part of the process wise are
important to have those q and A's and
that's a big of course part of being
there but again if you're not there I
just this it baffles me at times when
there's no participation from our
filmmakers and you can accept it it's a
big deal and we think it's very
important for those folks to represent
themselves at the festival not just
saying this is our festival but any
festival should if your films there if
you can of course depending on travel
whatever but if it's not you as someone
with the film or someone involved should
be representing the film it's an
opportunity to take that pass and and
you tell the stories and share about the
film and be in front of the audience and
and you have your moment to shine there
and to just not do anything with that
it's uh I just don't understand
sometimes to be honest Dan can you kind
of peel back the layer for us can you
take us through like the life of a
submission like suppose I'm submitting
my film whether I do it what is it
through film freeway or if I actually
mail it in what happens to that film
yeah well we'll tell you a quick story
for today I picked up a DVD and in our
mailbox today was the only one so far
for this whole year so this is like a
DVD is here like I was surprised that I
was surprised to get it to be honest it
used to be a time where was all DVDs and
we had it just the process of mailing
DVDs our mail was piled it was insane
and now it's nice and clean all
streaming the one DVD is like well is it
even here it's like an anomaly it's like
it's funny the times have changed you
know but but yeah we so for us the
majority of our submissions come through
film freeway now obviously we have other
platforms we're on we are on still
without a box although yes with our
boxes as everyone now knows uh the next
October they're they're closing up shop
so without a box is now done
we'll be defunct at that time so we are
still on without a box and then other
platforms a real port fest home
click-click for festivals so these other
platforms there a lot of those
International Film Festival Life all
these are either Australia Germany Spain
different countries that have their
platforms as well we're on essentially
many of the platforms for submission you
know process but film free way is our
main you know top one and our main one
that most people submit through so now
say for instance of film free way so
they send emails every time some of the
platforms and emails when the submission
comes in so man box are gonna email come
in and see these amount of films are
submitting as they come in so okay look
this this is the film this just came in
I'll take a look and then I go log in
and then I devote a certain time of the
day to watching a spare amount of films
each day and then from there I'm just
gonna go through that process of
watching films are coming in and you
know rate them we do 1 through 10 system
so that's how we judge our stuff is 1
through 10 along with of course notes to
go with that and flags flags meaning you
know green means this blue means this
there's different inside stuff we
designate to what a flag with me you
know orange my mean this there's
different colors we have that we can
designate to what that made my me for
our judges in it for us to look at so
when I go back and look I can say oh how
many of these are green this is what
green mean green means second-round or
you know I'm just throwing that out
there it's not necessarily that but you
know so there's a different process with
how we do the flags but the main thing
is still of course the scoring of a film
score is low it's you know not likely to
get a second look the film scores high
it's going to have a chance to get a
second look and then go on to a second
round of viewing after all the films are
watched so you know that score is a very
very critical part of the process but
yeah it simply put I look through the
films i watch a certain amount each day
whether it's sometimes five sometimes
just 10 to 20 sometimes even more and
I'm just looking through the films
watching them and scoring them and
putting my notes and saving him film
freeways great cuz I can save them other
judges that go in there or other people
like Theo and myself and Nicole we can
see each other's scores and notes I can
assign the film's to other judges or to
them and so they can see hey if I send
something to that maybe I already like
it and want to see it so hey Theo check
this one out and put a note and so we
can come and communicate that way and
yeah so that's the film for your process
it's similar in some other platforms but
not exactly the same with how they use
their system for judging we have a
separate document that we create a
spreadsheet with all of the film's so we
can score and put notes in there that
way we can always make sure there's a
place that we have them so we know that
we watched it because again all these
platforms are different without a boxes
system of how they do
notes and scoring isn't the same as a
freeway and fest home is different so on
and so forth they're not all the same as
far as how they're set up for scoring so
we use those master documents to make
sure we keep track all the films and all
the scores so when we go in there we can
you know make sure that we can see it or
if I want to see a film and and I double
check hey look if you already saw this
and he gave this a score and this is
this judge saw this and gave this score
and there's their notes and and then
that kind of thing so basically the
score are the notes you know are a big
part of it obviously and in the beauty
of some freeways you could save it there
and you know have it ready to go and
anyone can view it if they have access
to view and so we can kind of share
notes internally that way where it's
saved and lives on the application in
our back-end when we save the score on
the notes so yeah so that's the kind of
a little look into that process it's
basically a two full thing it's using
the systems that are in place like fest
home film freeway without a box all that
and to our best as far as scoring and
saving notes so it's always living there
you can go find it on the application
but also having our spreadsheet that we
have a master document where we import
all the submissions from all the
different platforms and things so we can
always double check and put our scores
in there and make sure we have another
place that we're not missing a score or
missing notes and where a film gets
washed and doesn't have a score notes so
we always have a place to kind of a
backup to make sure we have all the
information we need as far as scoring
and all that they're from different
judges so of a film that is going to
make it into the actual festival that's
in August every year how many eyeballs
have been on that that film that
actually makes it into the 400 that
makes it to the festival um I mean
that's at least that's at least at that
point at least three people at least if
found maybe even sometimes more we have
our mean of course there's myself the
own accord sorry three of us right there
so generally for those films at that
tier that level if not two or three of
us have watched maybe not stay for
instance maybe at some point myself and
Nicole watch and until Theo about it you
know we don't have to like approve each
other like I program the fest so if I'm
in the end reviewing all the stuff based
on the notes and then other judges and
we decided this film this film is
acceptance this is amazing the Zen we
talked about it it's in it I don't have
to have all three of us watch a film to
accept it going sense you know so you
can sort of bypass that so sometime
maybe not all three of us have watch it
you know and I guess at that point would
matter it's accepted it's in so there's
still great so no but yeah so it's still
at least two of the three of us and then
of course there's a view team involved
and so initially so if say we've
assigned a certain films to the review
team and say hey you judge hey you're
gonna watch this is your batch of films
you're watching these you give me your
scores and notes and your thing and do
all that they're okay they watch the
films I go in and I'm gonna review all
their stuff okay these films got these
scores this is what has a chance is when
doesn't this one I want to see what
these are and there's certain tier level
of scores I'm gonna be watch all those
and then see you know what's going on
with those are those going on a next
round do I agree with their score I
think their score is poor do I think
their scores amazing do I think they
even scored too low this is even better
than I expected and all even added my
even notes and they could average and
film for you as a system where averages
to note two scores so one judge a
watches films they they give this an
eight eight and have their notes this is
why and they gave it a thumbs up and
this is this okay well I think this
thing is actually better I think this is
a nine this is incredible I'll put my
notes in and my thing and then also save
that it averages both scores together so
now the score will go to 8.5 just doing
easy math nine eight you know the
average is out eight point five now so
now I bump to score up a bit and I'll
note that this is a second round viewing
and I've watches now for a second round
and this has a chance and whatever I'll
put my notes in there for that too we're
gonna come back to that film that film
is now sort of moved on the next round
and that's kind of how that process
works or the opposite could be true
judge walks watches it they give a
certain score i watch you know disagree
with the score this is even this isn't
it this is not gonna be something that's
gonna be acceptable for our standards
it's not gonna make the festival put a
certain score in note that and at that
point that's sort of it's got its second
viewing and it's now essentially going
to be rejected so if that makes sense so
that's kind of that's how that can go so
usually there's generally a lot of times
a to viewing process is our goal now
sometimes I doesn't happen because the
film's score so poorly you know that
amongst all the films and the amount of
films are submitted is that that low of
a score quality isn't there it's it's
not going to get a second viewing not
likely outside of a double check of like
myself or Theo or us checking and
double-checking the films
because sometimes I've seen films or a
review team person gave something a won
and it was actually not a won it was
actually a ten because of the drastic
each of the film that the judge was
actually very so I guess it's just a
offended by it sure we thought it was
actually incredible and in the film I
shouldn't get making the festival so
there was the opposite so you have to
double-check scores whether it's even
very low or very high it's is to make
sure where the the sort of head is that
of the reviewer so again talk about the
film for a festival and it fell on her
when we thought there our standards what
we're looking for you know so now that
was a drastic example because the film
was a bit graphic in nature and ready
yeah I won't get into details on that
but the good it was but it was very
interesting fascinating film very good
so but that's that's part of the process
you have to double-check things because
sometimes you know you don't want things
to fall through the cracks and it's it's
not easy it's not always possible I mean
there's so many films and and it's it's
blessing that's great but it's also
difficult but we do want to always sort
of stay on top of all of it because
again you can find those those films
that I would have been very disappointed
if that film didn't make the vestal we
felt really strongly about and and about
the filmmaker about the the actual movie
so you know that's why you got to double
check films and try to watch twice and I
just watch once and just let it fall by
the wayside but again it's not easy now
not all films can get that second
viewing and they're viewing at times but
that's the goal is to go to rounds and
have films watch more than once because
also there's how you feel when you watch
the film if you watched fifty films are
you tired or you're like I'm over this
you don't want to judge based on being
grumpy or not in a mood that's not fair
you want to make sure that has another
viewing say okay this looks really good
that's an interesting elements I like
the story but maybe it's as slow-moving
for my taste right now but I'm also you
know watch 40 movies or something I'm
tired that's not something you want to
judge on that's not fair you want to
make sure okay let's put this aside you
watch it assign another just let them
take a look and see if they agree with
your scores they like it better like a
worse what are their thoughts because
again we are review team and the people
that are reviewing that gone through the
process in our our folks we trust their
word we trust now that they're gonna
obviously judge in our sort of style and
way so yeah at that point we're
comfortable passing it on and seeing
what they think but that's a big thing
it's like that's not also judged based
on you know just
mood of like how you know how I'm
feeling you know uh mad I had a bad day
you know I'm going to be harsh like
that's you know it's human nature you
have to try to fight against not being
impartial or in a bad place and just
like judging based on that just because
something's not maybe for you it's not
me that I'm not the person I'm not the
audience I'm just someone who should try
obviously judge basically I think is
fitting for the festival but I'm not the
audience does that make sense so it's
but it's that's also it you have to try
to humble yourself that way right it's
not normal way of watching something
you'd be like some of your leg is great
I hate something you hate it you hate it
there's a personal preference of things
in life we all have preference but it's
not always about the preference it's
about what is right for the audience
what is deserving of a spot not based on
what you know you know whatever was
something I love so much personally just
for me you know because it's not about
just me you know you does that make
sense
you said something Dan that was really
interesting you said that the films are
not programmed for you I'm sorry maybe
I'm paraphrasing but what what was it
you said they were just basically it's
we're watching the films I think we have
to try to accomplish what I'm trying to
accomplish and it's always a challenge
for anyone in our position these I think
is when you know we're not I'm not the
movies aren't for me to enjoy it's not
as if I'm program for myself it's not
I'm not the audience the audience is the
the festival goers not me so if I'm just
programming anything and everything I
like then it's just like it's Daniels
festival it's not about that it's not
about me and not about what I like
that's not the point of the festival is
not a point of programming that's but
that's a challenge right because ideas
when you're watching something you
inherently do you like it or not
that's part of the process and you enjoy
watching this do you like it or do you
not is it's human nature to feel that
way if you watch it and you like oh I
hate this film I don't like this I don't
like this about this huh you don't like
it or you're not enjoying it or it's not
for you you're gonna have a certain feel
away about you're not gonna love a film
and say oh this is not my I don't like
rom-com say let's just make it okay so
say that's the case and I'm watching a
romantic comedy we have this sort of sub
category where we screen a block of
romantic comedy film and I'm watching
and like all I just hate rom-coms I
don't like this and it's a great film
but I don't like it that's not the point
that can shouldn't I can't that's the
one where I shouldn't reject or score
poorly based on the fact that I
personally have a vested interest in
that or like the film that's not the
point of what we're programming the
audience is gonna judge that and other
ones watching the films and we're
programming for certain subcategories
and categories for a competition and for
an audience to see the film's whether
it's drama and narrative or you know
comedy documentary etc it's not about
hey I really love this so let's show
foreigner films at all just you know
action-adventure because I like that
like that that's stupid that's not what
we're doing so do you have to I think
the goal is that we're trying to not you
know more watching films and reviewing
not get too caught up in what just what
we like it don't like there's a personal
preference now that all said of course
it matters if you love a film and think
it was just fantastic and I personally
enjoy it heavily that is working in
their favor that is a good thing not a
bad thing
of course right I mean naturally but
that also doesn't mean it's guaranteeing
acceptance right to say hey this is in
and done no matter what anyone else says
they didn't and then it becomes a sort
of we're not running a dictatorship or
something it's kind of like you know you
have to there's a you know process in
place and you know we have to all agree
on certain things and also there is a
mount of films or programming based on
again genres style and you know timing
day time for family night time for you
know you know adult type programming
stuff or whatever so things like
that so there's a process in place and
it's not just about you know I hated
this movie so no it's out because I just
didn't like it that's really thing more
so that's what matters more liking is
one thing you love a film okay as a
chance to get any great whatever but the
opposite side of not liking something it
can be unfair that makes sense like to
just say I don't personally like this so
know what I'm gonna score this low and
reject this because I don't personally
like it that's I think that's that's a
challenge there and it's not fair so you
have to you know we're watching I think
the goal I have to remind myself
sometimes is that okay this is not not
everything's for me but it's not
supposed to be that way that's not what
it's about it's not about just my taste
that's just that's just simply not what
it's about
did you always feel that way or was that
a process that the three of you have
developed over time because that's
that's an interesting concept to think
about when it is you're you it's your
brand yeah well you know it is but again
it's also yeah it's about because again
you're trying to focus on different
stories and styles of storytelling but
really about the the quality of
filmmaking is really it's about that not
just about again the preference of
personal tastes so that's always that
challenge of and I think we just kind of
learn that over time I mean at least for
me personally I can really speak to
everyone else's processing things but I
think for me yeah I think it's learning
like anything else it's trial and error
and learning about you know because
we've seen some films as well that we
really loved or maybe it was a personal
thing and then we we see okay let's see
how this plays in the audience let me go
excited get the popcorn sit down and
watch you know because we watched some
occasional we get this actually sit and
enjoy some films here and there not too
often but it's nice to sometimes be able
to enjoy the festus well and just sit
down and watch something and then you're
taking it back where the reaction is not
what you thought you know wait not
everyone likes this like we thought look
and you feel weird like wait no one
actually responded the way I thought it
and we're like sometimes you don't be
the only one laughing oh that's so funny
you're like no one else is laughing
someone else likes this but we're
sitting here like yeah so excited about
this you know they didn't that's a weird
thing so now you can't ever get that
100% right this is not an exact science
it's all subjective everything is movie
can be simple to think of in a great
movie you think someone could think it
sucks is whatever it's never you know
this is not universal
but you know you I think it's something
we're trying to be cognizant of you you
want to at least be aware of and again
back to like very important as far as
the rejection part don't wanna just
reject something based on all I didn't
like this no reject it and I didn't
personally choice or I'm mad about this
or you know that's just not fair so it's
just something you have to try to I
think we got to try and keep in mind
have you ever had a filmmaker submit
their film to Holli shorts have it be
rejected and then come back to you and
say you know what you were right it
wasn't up to screening level then that
kind of I don't I really hasn't happened
that I can recall in the rec story no
and that's something I think is
interesting I think it should happen I
think you know there's various ways we
can do things to help encourage people
to come out like if if again if people
follow up they give you reject some
rejection letters people may not follow
up or saying anything quite frankly
we're not gonna like chase them down to
hey you should write back to me or give
me a response to my even reject you know
obvious we're not gonna chase that down
but many people responded with hey why
did I get in or some people said really
nice
elzar constructive criticism type emails
like asking for information or whatever
some people angry sometimes and of
course we're gonna probably ignore that
if it's really nasty that kind of stuff
you get all types of responses but we'd
like to see is more people respond with
hey I like to have a more thorough
discussion why why did I get in or
whatever and we'll say hey here's a diss
kind of past the screenings come to the
festival come check out the films
yourself and see what you see and we
compare and things like that compare and
contrast to work you know and come up to
us and talk to us of what you think or
maybe you'll see hey maybe my film
didn't live up to these standards and
now I understand why but that doesn't
happen it's very rare that that
filmmakers will accept the pass or after
that kind of email and actually come
take the pass and come attend the
festival and things that does happen
sometimes not very often but as far as
the next step of like coming up watching
the films and actually having a
conversation with us I've never had that
conversation to anyone like just come up
hey you know Danny I want to talk to you
real quick I saw the films I came you
guys offered this pass to come check out
some films I didn't make it any but I'm
here to see you know and and yeah you
know what I understand or I see these
films and I you know I learned something
about this and that or whatever the case
or just I don't feel like my film was up
to the par that kind of thing that just
never happened and I think that should
happen more often maybe they can come
and say you know what I don't get it I
still think my feels better fine well we
could have that conversation and at
least they'd be at the festival
attending watching other films taking
part the acceptance the rejection
doesn't mean you can't attend the
festival and take part you can still
anyone can buy a ticket regardless of in
or not or you're in the festival five
years ago you come back you can come buy
a ticket it's general public general
festival audience to come see films and
come see the festival and participate
and that should have more often I mean
they talked about at some of the film
schools you talk about films that don't
get in first films that do get in some
of the students of course being
disappointed by classmates or whatever
getting in they don't get in why don't
they come out how come they don't come
out and see the films as well and also
encourage that he should be at the
festival taking the films and see what
may may have now to work to your film or
why you know understand what's out there
right like if I'm in the ocean that's
that position I want to know what's out
there I want to know why what am i up
against what was the reason I didn't get
it like that's that's important
information and something it should be
chased down it should be they should be
knocking on our door to come to ten the
screenings and come to the festival not
oh well you know screw you guys
you suck know this idea that you know we
stalking it's knowing your
not mine or something and that's the
right mentality about it and that's
that's what I think is sort of
prevailing mentality is that it's never
anyone else's fault but the others are
ours and not to say again we you know we
can get things wrong I'm not sitting on
a powder horn or something you know but
it's true that there is probably as many
times a reason why maybe the film didn't
get in and there's it be good and in my
of a filmmaker to say you know what let
me go check these films out let me see
what's going on here with this festival
let me see what they're looking for them
you see let me get a little more
information or even research all the
festivals to know what you're submitting
to and things like that like it's just
part of the process you should know it
shouldn't be something to just act
blindly to like oh well my film is
amazing my friend my work is the best
and I just believe in a whole heartedly
so I don't care about anything else I'm
just submitting and I should get in and
and that's it because I'm great like
okay well that's not that's not
necessarily real life here so like you
know like that it'd be good if people
would actually take more initiative that
way and I'd be really happy and
pleasantly surprised to have it more it
just doesn't it's just you know even
offering the things like a pass
discounts and stuff where people can
encourage you can encourage them to come
out and check it out and see what's
water and see you know what other films
are there and maybe they can see what
did or didn't work or why didn't get in
you know like it's not something that's
that happens and it's just interesting
because should have more often it
doesn't just it's just rare is where do
you accept rough cuts yet for submission
you do okay do you recommend that I mean
I don't necessarily recommend it no no I
don't but it's also doesn't we had like
I can think of a few left I'm having one
right now like this one film that should
have made it that was a rough cut when
they submitted and it was a giant rough
cut to because there was a whole element
missing of a big part of the story with
the visual effects that would have
enhanced it made it much better when it
was done but knowing what was there and
what was to come
I can see how great the story could be
in the potential the film was and I was
really enjoying it so I knew that you
know of course I needed to see the final
cut to see what that was cuz the video
the visual effects were hideous then
that kills the whole thing but they were
great and it was really good it was fine
but it's I knew that wasn't like I had a
feeling that was going to be very good
and I loved the movie so it still worked
and getting in so I was a rough cut and
it was a big one in the sense that a big
element of the story was simply not even
there at that time
you know it's hard to describe without
getting into details of the story and
stuff but but yeah so yes so some rough
cuts and still make it in no problem so
it's not it's not some kind of determine
but it can be if it's how many how rough
are we talking here like some films are
they're pretty rough cuts is like okay I
can't even get out good this really is
and this as it stands this cannot
compete so I guess so I'm getting at is
if it's if it's too much of a rough cut
were there's still too many elements
missing it probably is best not to
submit that just for a deadline
especially because look I mean we have
our deadlines but okay early bird okay
you might save ten fifteen dollars or
something if you submit later vice-versa
maybe you submit early you save some
money later you if the panel it'll pay a
little more but I'd rather pay more
money and have a final cut if I can and
have a chance to get accepted in that
way and have my best work forward
instead of saying well I saved a few
bucks I'm gonna submit for that deadline
I'm so eager to get the deadline in so
if I give any advice like look don't
worry about that spend the extra money
it's we're talking not talking a hundred
dollars here we're talking fifteen bucks
ten bucks
difference of a deadline wait get it
ready and submit that instead of rushing
for that deadline just to submit it's
better to submit the final cut if you
can what are the top three reasons a
filmmaker will be rejected by a Film
Festival well I think one is first thing
and something that was thinking about
this a little more is time something
that's not even the fault of any
filmmaker at all it's some festivals and
at times even we see it with ours is
there's a you have a story you're
telling that that's that's sort of
redundant in the sense that it's a
category that's very heavy in a certain
areas like a style of storytelling right
so it could be sometimes it's traumas
where there might be a certain type of
story sort of heavy family drama that
might be so replicated by maybe ten
other films or maybe more that are
telling some of the very similar story
now and that if that happens as
programmers we're looking to program a
diverse range of films and are we gonna
show you know four or five six the same
types of stories and films and if we're
only selecting four hundred out of
thousands of films that's gonna be hard
to say yes to that so sometimes as they
no fault of any one's it's just more of
a situation of percentages and you're
telling a story that might happen to be
similar without getting too many details
of like specific story like a exact sex
story I'm not gonna like retell a story
you known to me like like it just it
falls under something that you have
we're seeing in this whole submission
pool like identical stories essentially
sometimes even very identical to the
point where if it's something of you
know like you know missing the the exact
verbiage here but like when the
filmmaker takes a story that's like
public domain and remakes a story
whether it's Stephen King short or
something like that right and they tell
that story you might see for submissions
of the same exact movie which is kind of
fascinating artists I were like hey who
did it better did it worse what worked
they're all different movies but they're
the same story now you're seeing films
they're literally the same story so at
that point who's gonna make any are we
gonna show all four of them even if
they're all great I mean you it hard to
say yes to that we're not going to show
the same movie over and over and we've
had it happen we're actually two films
are the same films I've actually made it
in the two same stories with different
types of films we made different films
made but same story so that can't happen
as rare but it has happened but most
times it's not gonna they're not gonna
get in like it's hard to say okay which
one if they're all great or maybe none
of them get in but what if one gets in
now we're gonna accept two more or
another one well generally speaking of
the same story now that's not something
you can control as a filmmaker how do
you know you made a film how do you know
that someone else made the same film how
do you know they submitted the you
wouldn't know that so that's not
something that you can actually control
so there's an element of
uncontrollability with that then there's
also the percentages as I mentioned it
we've went from the early years
twenty-three hundred seventy five
hundred thousand to now you know we're
talking five thousand plus submissions
same amount of spots we're not
increasing the festival to eat hundreds
Lots we're not going fourteen fifteen
days we're ten days around four hundred
films are generally make you give or
take based on runtime and everything and
you know five programs a day and this is
and also within that we have different
categories so we have to fill in the
blanks of what can fit based on genre
need in style and things like that
family films evening type stuff you know
different styles for different times and
things so now the percentages are
shrinking how many films can make it in
how many fit in that criteria of all
these films so that is already
inherently a
a competitive situation we're talking
five to maybe 10% of all submissions
that will generally essentially get
accepted
so now inherently that's already we're
saying potentially 90% may not even make
it and I'm they've been talking about
scores I'm talking about anything else I
have just the numbers there so then
that's already again inherent honest
portrayal of the competitive nature so
there's that so and now I said all that
then we get into okay now what's wrong
then the next step is the next thing
we're looking at of course isn't any of
the potential flaws whether it's
technical stuff technical issues that
are you know whether it's just the
obvious things of poor jump cuts or you
know obviously boom mic and shots these
kind of obvious things any of those
things that's it that's like a sort of
automatic rejection of sorts basically
you were limiting yourself in that sense
just because of those those errors or
edits or issues so there's that and then
you get into okay how is the acting how
is the storytelling how is the writing
how is the cinematography or the
technical aspects of the film you know
if if some of those are okay Vande some
of them are really poor you're gonna
have a lower score you're just gonna get
rejected it's not going to make it you
know and again that's the standard based
on we're talking our festival at this
time I don't know other festivals have
less emissions maybe there's more slots
or different things that they have going
on but when you look at that at that
aspect of it those are there's some of
those elements that are for us it sort
of it can it can make its own automatic
you're sort of rejecting yourself in
some sense if there's some of those
areas are flawed and then of course
technical stuff is off those things are
sort of automatic then you get into
after all that you know what are we
looking to program how is the
storytelling is it unique that's a big
thing like we're looking for at times
watching so many films and our review
team and myself watching so many films
it's always exciting and something
that's something that's desirable that
you know that a film and a story is very
you know whether it's outside the box or
just unique or different stands out in a
big way know now that can be a lot of
things whether it's just very whether
it's very graphic or whatever or
wherever whatever it's if it's just
something unique style of storytelling
or visually very different or whatever
that may mean
but that that's a big deal because
that's gonna you like in all these films
and if something this could arise at the
top you like wait this is I've never
seen this before there's something is
very unique and we've never seen it
before we've seen all these films that's
something that's obviously going to
whale on our minds we're not going to
forget that
so I guess we're long in the way of
saying just try not to be forgettable
you don't forget it we'll make it
something that's just like wow is
everyone watching that you walk away
it's saying why I can't believe that
film that was amazing because you know
there are many stories that that are I
guess playing it safe you know where the
filmmaker storyteller is not really
trying to push boundaries or we're not
trying to you know and not trying to do
something different they want to make
maybe it's just in those in the
filmmaking style you know maybe there's
a lot of two shots not trying to get
into any any too much can't now I know
this budget restraints and things of
course but within that you have to be
creative and show your style if it's not
how is that gonna stand out amongst the
whole crowd of all these films if you
don't your chances of being sucked at
that point become very very very low it
just it's just the numbers game is there
it's it's very difficult so yeah I think
it's a that's uh without talking
technical stuff the big thing is when
films are to relax a bit a word I guess
vanilla you're kind of shooting yourself
in the foot for us at least that's just
definitely we've seen so many films if
nothing stands out about it how is it
gonna be unforgettable for us if it's
not forgettable then we're just probably
gonna forget it in its innocence right
so that that's that's it that's
important you think people are taking
less risk or more risk in terms of the
storytelling aspect pushing boundaries
just be just sort of being these like
agent provocateurs like putting stuff
out there that's like whoa and some
people gonna be really offended by it or
you think it's it's less so I mean yeah
well that's always it are we to PC yeah
maybe I mean well I don't know we it's
tough to say because I I see a lot of
stuff that's not so I'd say no then but
then the same time there's a lot of
we're also living in this new age of
sort of being checked online PC culture
like don't say this don't say I don't do
this and it's just this this sort of of
course you know there's like this online
battle going on with all this stuff
whether it's cyber bullying or just
people just so the mob mentality of
jumping on people for certain things you
say the wrong thing and it's forget
about it and stuff like that so
that isn't really I still like that
doesn't play much into the films I think
people are trying to really push Braun
to tell really great stories and and
share what they believe in and also show
their vision and style because again
this is also goes back to the beginning
of what it is Schwartz always were and
still are at some degree of course a
calling card you're trying to say hey
look at me world this is what I do this
is what I can do this is my ability I'm
showing you this in what you know what a
restraints I'm up against there's how
much money I have is what I can do
within this this what is this restraint
right like hey I got ten grand is what I
got to make with it and I can I can make
a kick-ass film okay well that's what
you're trying to do so if you can I do
that you know you're making a you know a
seven minute you know short that's just
you know I don't know as a drama that
we've seen before retold a certain story
that's been done many times by many
filmmakers and there's nothing original
to it and there's no new touch to it or
anything else it's like you're not gonna
see many acceptances at that point you
know it's like it's gonna so you really
want to see people take a chance whether
it's just something that's provocative
or something that's adventurous or just
out there or if it is political or
something that's trying to make a stance
or a stand or just you know make a big
strong point you still got it you got to
try to show that but what you gotta try
to do it
you know and yeah I mean all that said
though some people do want to make the
film they want to make you have to make
your film you can't try to make
something and try to be someone you're
not so there's always that it always is
that but it's how you tell even the
symbols of stories how well you do it
visually and how it's how you showcase
your abilities is what it's about cause
we're trying to showcase what we feel
are the best films in the world that's
the goal that's the idea so if it
doesn't fall under that or doesn't feel
like it it belongs in that or it's that
exciting then why are we gonna put all
of our chips on it or really push it all
forward and say this is what we have to
showcase it has to be accepted and
there's other ones not to get rejected
you take that place of all the other
films yeah it's like you almost there's
like you commit to like make it say why
like convince us so that's that's you
know that's part of it yeah there was
one film that I just I can still see it
to this day as it was about a woman who
had been raped and she ended up having a
child and she loved that child and the
child finds out that it's a product of
rape but I mean not that film
was unbelievable and I realized that
some people be very scared to do that
yeah especially in today but I mean to
me I thought that was an amazing yeah I
know you guys have shown some very you
know things that really push boundary
but but there's reasons for that and
they're really amazing so I ya know and
it's also for us has been a joy of like
we we're in a position with this as and
I've said it before I week and we have
the opportunity to dictate what we want
to do with the festival with the style
with with everything with parties events
whatever part of the plan of the event
or whatever we show whatever it gets
screen its is exciting to have obviously
a say in something in this world right
where we can say this is what we feel is
the best way to do this is how we and we
believe in this and we can do that so
with that we obviously have opportunity
and and and also responsibility to try
to do the best we can with it
and if we're giving a stamp of approval
we're sort of trying to be as many
festivals to be gatekeepers or saying
this is what we need to show you as an
audience this is what you need to pay
attention to Hollywood look at these
filmmakers in these films because this
is what what we believe are the best the
best is well believed you need to look
at this is the film these are the films
you need to pay attention to that's what
we're doing you're shining a light on
these films that's the obviously we're
doing a saying these ones come take a
look at these the other ones didn't
quite make it and raise your reasons or
whatever but there's the ones we believe
in strongly you have to obviously come
see these movies so you know that's a
responsibility though we also have to
take serious and I just throw up
anything on screen just because we you
know feel like we owe someone something
or something that's just not you know
that's not what that's about but you
know I think when the the more films and
filmmakers are pushing those boundaries
what a lot of festivals are doing like
Sundance and they program a lot of stuff
that you'll see over the years as also
push boundaries been very you know
unique and aggressive in their
storytelling their styles and and not
pulling back or holding back for fear of
what people react to it what they'd say
you know that's you know especially
there's something to see the voice you
want to really share what you have to
say and you believe in it doesn't make
sense to be restrained or pull back just
based on fear of reaction or what people
might think of you or something that's
not gonna work and if you do that your
your your chances of being something
that many festivals or any are very low
at that point so it's you know yes you
guys tell us where you got to tell but
that also means if it
is more of a film that doesn't require
that kind of it was not a provocative
story or things like that it can be more
of a simple kids film or something
that's fine but if it's the opposite
it's supposed to be quite it's very
provocative story and things don't also
pull the curtain back or pull back a bit
you know like it's I think of a quote
that sought recently it was dealing with
that same subject of like you know when
it came to a film that was very it was
telling a war story and they were saying
there was a responsibility to not you
know pull back on how aggressive an
awful that is because if you're not
showing what that really is that you're
doing that is service the people think
oh this is okay this is this is not that
bad you know you can't walk away feeling
away that's not what we should be
portraying as a situation of showing
what it means to be in war or as violent
awful and terrible and sad to make that
feel like it's not you know that's at a
service so that's something that I think
people should really keep in mind and
that's something I've always kind of
thought of when I think back to that
quote and forgive I can actually member
an exact quote
and so I'm paraphrasing someone of
something I saw recently and I remember
it has stuck with me and in
documentaries watching it was it's very
important to show how how awful things
like that can be and if you're telling
that story not telling the PC way you
know to make sure it is what it's
supposed to be and it is also aggressive
and things like that or whether it is
violence or sad or depressing not make
it less depressing
you mentioned the thing about rape and
then like don't make that be something
that's like not awful or sad like make
it feel like it's just okay or just
that's then that's just don't told to
service anyone who's ever been a victim
of anything like that's you know it's
very important to not how that be the
case and so yeah as long when the answer
is basically yeah just make sure to you
guys go all the way ya know and and the
filmmaker spoke afterwards and you know
they gave a very I won't go into too
much hopefully we can put a link to it
in this video below but I mean it was it
was amazingly done and and they talked
about it and I remember I just went up
to the filmmaker afterward and just you
know thanked them because it was just it
was an incredible story and although
they were trying to show that this this
mother loved this child you know they
had to go to certain places that might
make certain people a little
yeah and challenging for those actors
involved in the project and that's right
but that's you know anything we're
telling is you know it's needs to be
that and that's deciding when you see
that it's for us exciting we're like
well wait while we have a chance to
actually show this and let the story be
told and give it sort of a life if it's
a real premiere like well we got the
shows the first time like an audience
can see this now and this is the work
they put in and the chances they take in
an hour you get to showcase that that's
you know it's pretty cool so that's
that's obviously something that we were
able to do here this is part of the
blessing to be able to do this this work
is they showcase films like that you
know give them the chance or they're
there or that's the first chance or
their only chance or whatever or if it's
in the show in the movie 20 times
already and we're like the twenty first
screening okay it's great but we're
getting a chance to show it to our
audience and another audience can see it
again and that's that's awesome so
that's something we're obviously don't
take for granted should a filmmaker ever
stop submitting to festivals um I'd say
maybe I'd say maybe I mean it really
depends on what their their goals are
for their films or their film you know
obviously on one hand I'm gonna say no
you know I mean I'm a we're first of all
so yeah you know submissions are a big
part of life blow if s though we
obviously rely upon that we need a we
need the films it's a competing at each
other we need to see the best of the
best we need to receive them if we don't
receive them we have no festival and B
of course a portion of a budget of the
festival is revenue from sales revenue
from our sponsors have advertising
ticket sales and submissions so it's
obviously part of what needs to be there
so we can obviously keep the lights on
or whatever so to speak so it's
important but at the same time not every
film is meant to be in festivals so you
know there's stuff made where there's
just more of something that's more maybe
it's something comedic for the web or
something it is not really a festival
type film where it's gonna compete for
every prizes or maybe try to be an
oscar-nominated film so there's some
examples where you might argue like look
maybe it's not best for you to submit
the festivals or just and not submit so
many blindly just like looking at hey
there's a cool fest when we submit
understand what you're submitting to
that's more big that's a bigger part of
it knowing what festival is look for
what kind of films do a said festival
like your comedy or do they never show
comedies and the only show
narrative dramatic films and the only
show maybe you know a festival it's all
about horror and they don't want
or whatever like that kind of thing if
you didn't know that I don't pay
attention to that and just kind of
submit everything just because hey look
please cool names I know these festivals
I like them I've been to it and was cool
let me just submit my film but not
understanding what your chances are at
that point then yeah you're essentially
just sort of handing your money over to
the festival and watch it and they think
it's cool but doesn't fit their thing
you know we now have the Hollywood
comedy shorts festival as we started
four years ago that's our sister
festival it's comedy and we've seized
submissions that come in they're
literally not funny not none to say not
good comedy not like not funny not funny
as in they're just straight dramatic and
narrative films are dramas so we can't
like okay you submit it to our festival
but we're not the number of not just one
or two films it's a bunch of films and
we're surprised like wait I was okay and
sometimes I can flag them I said look
when we will show us it monthly
separately and then have a different
conversation with them because there's a
good film but this is simply does not
fit this festival at all like we're
looking the name is comedy we were
looking for various kind of comedy but
we're looking for comedy and if there's
not one joke or comedic element to the
film at all it's not how we're gonna
it's not getting in I mean we're not
looking for those kind of films right so
then they just submitted to a festival
nine paying attention and if you do that
then you're just wasting time and money
that at that point so there is something
to be said for making sure you pay more
attention to where you're submitting
research the festivals understand what
the festival look for you know you could
look over their program guide some of
them are online you know Holly shorts is
our guides are on Easter calm so you can
find them on these these websites on our
website we've also put the links so we
have them on there so you can see the
programs from the past five years hey
let me look at 2015-16 so what are they
been programming me yeah I get it I get
it that takes more time who has time for
all that right but if it's something
you're obviously taken serious here
there is time to be made for this this
is important to research this stuff to
pay attention to what films play where
what kind of films they like don't like
again some festivals just don't like
certain kind of films but that doesn't
mean they're not taking your submission
that's the thing obviously the Comedy
Festival because they came in they
submit it we don't control comes our way
gets submitted the links there people
can go to film freeway and some at the
film so if you submit your film
incorrectly that way we're not watching
the film now and saying okay we're gonna
just hand your submission back you give
your money back no that's not happening
we've watched the film than the work and
you submit it and you try to compete and
it's not
right place so if you're doing that
that's just on the filmmakers part
that's just sort of I guess essentially
wasting their own money any responsible
like you got to know what you're looking
for what goals you have for your film
where do you want to be what kind of
festivals what cities you want to play
in well cities you think are nine points
to play what are you thinking I don't
really want to play into the city
because I don't really care I don't want
to go there I don't know whatever like
there's different reasons for submitting
different festivals different places and
I think that's bigger part of it I mean
there is the opposite end of that word
again some films just not meant for
festivals perhaps and it's not something
that's meant to be submitted to
festivals then find it then you
shouldn't omit at all and just say okay
this film is only meant to be online to
share with some friends or just post
online if it's some little silly thing
and I only made it a few minutes with no
money you know I don't know something
like that but if it's something you are
of course taking serious you want to get
an audience and showcase and build your
film up and build your career up then
yeah I do believe in festivals I think
yes you'd be submitting to festivals so
I guess really depends on the film well
then on the flipside how does a
filmmaker know that it's time to submit
to a festival like suppose they have
something that they've worked on and
they feel that it's ready how do they
know it's ready well again you know that
would go back to what we talked about
earlier is not just about research
vessels been going to the festivals
because you'd also be surprised how many
filmmakers are just starting off there
may be submitting festivals and actually
never really gone to any festivals and
it's like okay you've never been in the
festivals maybe never been to ours or
some other festival just made too and
some of that of course obvious reasons
if you live in Los Angeles maybe you're
not gonna go to DC for DC shorts or have
you never been in New York City so
you've never been in Tribeca or whatever
you know like that okay that's obvious
but still you shouldn't attend whatever
festivals are in your area so if you do
live in Los Angeles there's a ton of
course festivals in Los Angeles to
attend ours and others and and there's
also than California Co San Diego or San
Francisco I mean you can go to festivals
other places as Las Vegas so you know
attend the festival see what's out there
see what a festival film might look like
you go to these vessels say hey my film
was much better than these films I'm
saying all these vessels okay I feel
like my film holds up against this so
I'm gonna submit these festivals I think
you could play here and I think it's
better than these films okay
good if you have no idea and never seen
the trailer has never seen the festival
trailer never seen photos of the
festival never seen lineup of the film
how do you know your film fits any of
that
I mean I guess I can grant it some films
just a certain level of caliber
production a lot of money spent time
effort it's as if the film walks you
walk away you watch you're like I feel
really good about my film this is a
great film I feel really confident yeah
you can just submit so much of that
that's fine but I mean not every film
fits all the festivals and maybe that
you know maybe even after the production
is done you know you haven't looked at
other fest and seen what's out there you
also never done it before
maybe the film doesn't hold up as much
you think of course sometimes every
person making any films of all produce
made films feels better about their film
than maybe the film is you know there's
always a sort of confidence of like you
know your films the best you know of
course so so there is an element of how
do we tell ourselves the truth and
things like that but you know it's so it
is hard to say but I think there's a
process in place where you can just at
least research the fest as more 10 more
festivals to be there and see in person
what's playing at the festivals because
many of them you can't see the films
online perhaps so you only can see him
in person at the festival so you see the
films go to the festival check it out
vibe these things out and see then
you'll know okay my phone compares to
this or my film doesn't compare to this
maybe you you be realistic and
understand that the film doesn't fit the
mold of what the festivals are looking
for what you're seeing does we see
people at our screenings all time to
come out talk to us like wow it's very
inspired by these from these films
quality's great I didn't know what to
expect I wasn't blown away by this these
films are really good you know I know I
understand what this is like or this
kind of thing like you know like they
get understanding after seeing films and
seeing a few blocks of appreciation that
it if they didn't go they'd have no idea
so you know and by doing that they could
have a better understanding of me my
film is up for this I mean my film is
not I need to submit elsewhere or try to
do this instead or maybe make a
different film or maybe hold off on this
one or you know things like that so it's
just I think attending the festivals is
of course a big wave under saying that
maybe I'm in the dark here but do we
hear as much about webseries as before I
feel like we don't hear as much about
webseries um well I know I think I think
we still I think you still do I think
there's yeah I mean well it the general
term of webseries is kind of I guess too
broad right because what what is that is
it just something that's continuous
series you make and post online it's on
YouTube or maybe on potentially on a
Vimeo or as other platforms or is it
that or are we talking what YouTube's
res done where YouTube is read you
- red is now obviously producing content
and making their own series so they are
actual you know are they just actual
series are they webseries because
they're on YouTube but they're for pay
and they're you know of course of a
bigger budget and you know now you're
having some name recognition people in
the big talent you know attached to
these projects so is that also a
webseries so I guess what are we
defining as webseries has grown so much
from when it was just you know
independent filmmakers really trying to
make a name for themselves make their
own series and you get a following well
you still see a lot of that and some of
it works really well and they have a
following built up and obviously doing
episodic so you have to come back the
hook ability of like oh I want to come
back and see the next episodes you have
to wait for and that kind of thing you
know that's the normal traditional thing
but a lot of that's changed now now you
also have streaming with Netflix and
everyone with their shows are saying
okay well we're just dumping the show
the whole thing and binge it and watch
all 13 episodes and it's on you know
February 5th and it's on and instead of
the traditional way of hey come back
from work I'm going every week weekly
maybe daily or whatever that web series
might be here whatever the series is
doing HBO every week Game of Thrones
every week you know Netflix in them or
just whoever they just dump it on there
and you can just binge it and see
everything right then and there when
it's airing that's different that's a
different thing that's change that's
change things as well but I still think
there's there's a big audience for
webseries to think especially when it
comes to what is a younger audience
looking for that sort of beyond the doll
audience they like this stuff but you
know again it has to match their needs
and desires of what they're looking for
you know what kind of comedy what kind
of writing what kind of actors and cast
you know the things they're looking for
did that fit them so you know you're
seeing stuff serving them and I think
some of what YouTube's doing with that
is focusing on that younger audience
trying to hook them into - watching this
content you know another does their name
talented people that they like so it's
not something that relates to me I when
I see some of these things and you know
I'm like I don't know I don't but I'm
not really into those those things that
they're putting out I don't like those
shows that's not something that's gonna
attract me is you know again coming up
on his 40s is a male not like a 16 year
old teenage girl like they're looking
for this stuff it's a different audience
there but you know it's being serviced
so the content is being made for them
and so we're seeing a lot of stuff
that's still on web and and for us
submission wise you're still seeing time
web series
a ton a lot of webseries come in there's
a lot of TV pilots and stuff they're
obviously trying to also go the TV route
now because you can pitch it's a network
sing a pitch the streaming you know it's
streamers and stuff there's a new need
and desire for TV content and instep
asada that way
so you're seeing pilots made for that
but webseries is still very healthy as
far as a submission for us is what we
see as far as what's coming our way
and I still see there's there's a ton of
them now how good they are popular they
are that's something that's like a SAN
question as far as the popularity or you
know how many of yous are getting in
this kind of thing but we see some that
are really awesome
they have no views and no know following
with their fantastic and some that are
have a huge following that are kind of
silly honestly her I don't think you
very good or don't make it because
they're not they're just not strong
enough the content of the story or just
acting it we just find that some of it's
not really for the festival but did have
a big following so it's hard to say but
there's still a ton being made so it's
still something I think is very very
prevalent do you think youtubers are as
apt to submit to your festival as just
what would be a regular quote-unquote
filmmaker you know I know there's a lot
of controversy over oh well you know a
youtubers not a filmmaker which I don't
necessarily agree with but you know do
you think some of these more named
youtubers or people with a larger
YouTube following are willing to submit
to a festival versus someone who's like
no I'm an auteur on the filmmaker well a
little bit again a little bit of both
because for us we have the actual
category so since we are covering web
series and TV with categories we were
able to actually accept those
submissions and see them come come our
way but that said still a lot of if you
say youtubers or people or maybe
extremely famous built their brand up
strictly on the YouTube sort of what
their subscription channels or at their
own platform and I kind of think on
YouTube or you know we don't see as many
of those you know whether it's a ton of
fun to write like you know especially
going back to a young audience like
talking teenagers there there's just
certain like influencers right that's
the word the influencers some of these
influencers we're not seeing as many of
them submit going honestly so I guess
there is it I guess it disconnect to
some way there's some of them do we have
had some and we screen something we've
had some a Tyra Festival before so there
are some but as a whole like it's not a
heavy majority and I like all of them
are coming our way or submitting to
festivals to me
first of all so there is a sort of I
guess there is a that's not the right
word disconnect but there is definitely
you see there's a sort of difference as
far as who's sending to festivals and
what their goals are
I suppose they feel if you are I guess a
quote unquote influencer you maybe that
means you have millions of followers
something and you're making you know
quick hitting web series content or like
stuff that's kind of good for snapchat
that kind of stuff like is that
something that's gonna fit for the
festival they probably look at it like
probably not and maybe they're even
probably right you know but they also
have a huge following and they become
famous and they're all right you know so
where does that lie for the festivals I
don't know for us it's definitely it's
kind of there is a I guess I just
connect there it's not something that
we're seeing a ton of you know maybe
that's something to explore as far as a
category for that war an area of another
festival or maybe there's a festival to
be had just covering the sort of that
area like a festival just for you know
that sort of elk of a youtuber or
filmmaker that's just it's got a big
following that way you know I don't know
we don't personally put any judgement I
don't for us I don't feel like we care
if you're influenced are not big
following though following
we're trying to just take a look at is
this good or not is this fit them
although we're looking for for the
webseries categories is good for said
categories and that's it that's where
that's the goal and if it isn't great
and if it is not which some of it isn't
because I've seen some of this stuff
some of stuff is like I don't know I
just not for us it's not for me it's not
it isn't it wouldn't fit an exhibition
screening of like you know the festival
it just doesn't you know whether it's
just a few seconds or as 10 20 second a
little sort of cutaway clips and it's
like a bunch of episodes where it's like
silly punchline jokes and stuff doesn't
really have any production value at all
and you know like that's but people love
them and I have this huge following not
to name names so I won't specify anyone
but you know I just it's it doesn't
maybe fit so you know yeah well you
mentioned you know influencers or people
that are famous
so in selecting films how important is
the celebrity factor I mean do you think
maybe it was more important before and
less so now because there's so much
great content there kind of kind of I
mean it's it's always gonna mean
something to any festival or and you can
sit here in LA and say
means nothing like people say that
that's just the flat I like it can't be
that right because you're a festival
you're an event you also part of that is
trying to be draw an audience and
obviously make a name for the said
festival or events and you know some of
these names can be a big draw would it
matter does it not matter if not just
throwing it say Denzel Washington's in a
short Enzo Washington not matter come on
we can't sit here and say that doesn't
matter right if that's the case you're
gonna there's an element of excitement
to that potentially that also means
probably that if he's doing something
like that it's going to be good the odds
of someone like him doing something
that's just bad that'd be very
surprising so there is that part of it
too so some people say oh it's just
celebrities is why I got an or this kind
of thing you see celebrity well no I
mean you know that said celebrities not
doing just anything and they're not
gonna do something that's that's awful
you know like there's gonna be a quality
to that there probably have a certain
money behind it they're probably gonna
have a great crew behind it
the directors probably knows what he's
doing is he's worked on other things
with them or something
so there's gonna be a certain I guess
level of advantage to that so you'll
find that so then then I guess our
chances are increasing now that said if
we had a film last year that I won't go
get name any names but number of
celebrities number of talent
it was awful awful awful awful and I had
to pass it on every as I looked we have
to why me I'm not alone that's right
we're all like wow what happened here
now we're wondering who bribed to how
didn't someone do this why did they do
the movie we're learning what is going
on here that made them actually -
because it was it's just I just can't it
was better it was just really bad it was
very poorly made across the board lazy
poor Scimitar if you're poor editing
acting was a silly and even though said
actors were very good they're also
giving poor performance so there was an
element of laziness even taking what I
just said I just said how you know
usually they're gonna see a certain
talent do something really good and
they're gonna work on something only
because that you know they believed in
it right and they're good and they're
talented they know what they're doing is
they're smart and they're huge stars in
this case was the opposite it was like
what is going on here why are they doing
this like I don't understand my point
where I almost want to just email and
call one like a what happened here what
was the story I need a back story of
this because how could you possibly get
these people to do this because it was
like so obviously was an easy rejection
it was rejected there's no way we can we
can't screen something like that just
because some names are in it like
doesn't there are other films now with
names and people who are recognizable in
all types of films and content short
webseries in short series and in the
films it's just the nature of it now
because you've seen more people make
shorts and the short space has grown
which is great for us and now we're
seeing more talented people involved in
the films whether it's an actor from a
TV show or someone from Game of Thrones
it's shorter they want to produce their
own film and direct the film and they're
starting and they're doing a short and
then you have you know another big actor
that wants to direct and write and star
in something and you know or they just
believe in a project and want to produce
it I mean you're seeing all types of
involvement from celebrities now more so
than it was before when it was early on
was like whoa this person doing this Wow
it was like it was a certain it was a
well factor to that it was something he
got excited about and that guy couldn't
have hurt them obviously it was it was
something that probably helped to get
accepted in those kind of things you saw
that but now that part but also a couple
with we are now a bigger festival we
believe what we're doing we believe that
the work has stand out it's competitive
so there's more level playing for the
competition and the quality is gonna
stand out it's not just like oh well we
need this name person to attend so we
got to put it in that mentality we're
not some growing festival we just
started we're like we're like starving
for attention kind of thing we don't
need that that way so we're not gonna
just bend over backwards just to do that
just for a talent just because like so
there is a part of us or growth has
helped us to sort of negate that so I
think that's part of it too I think that
there there definitely is a sort of
difference of playing field now with
that like as opposed to 50 years ago -
now you tell me you're one weed that
wouldn't matter to have star talents in
our festival we had 23 movies in two
days and it was like some of those
movies would never make it now look of
course it's different it wouldn't matter
but you go back you fast-forward 15
years now amount of films we see then
when a film's will come through our way
our doors you know it's it's definitely
more competitive now to where it's not
just where just because someone's in a
film it's gonna get a pass or something
now it's definitely no more competitive
that way so Dan we know that you love
sports and let's say you had five
minutes to sit down with a short
filmmaker before they make their short
film and you're their coach what are you
gonna coach them on what are you know
say to them they haven't made it yet
maybe they're ready to go they might
have a script yeah I think the biggest
thing is is
going back to its belief belief on what
your the story you're trying to tell
belief in the subject matter you know
and I say that in the sense of you you
can't anything you do whether it's this
festival if you are in sports if you you
know our say you're a basketball coach
and but you don't love basketball how
are you going to put that passion energy
into actually doing it well and being
succeeding you can't you're not you're
going to fail you will lose you will
fail same with a story or a film you
want to get together and make a film
with a group of people and you have to
rally up grips DP their crew pas
assistants to follow you and help in any
way you need actors to say okay I'm
going to emotionally give to you and I'm
not ready to do this because you don't
seem that interested or that vested in
this or you don't believe in the story
or you don't know anything about the
story so that's why I go back to also
when I said earlier like you have to
tell a story you know like tell the
story you know that you can tell you can
make don't like try to do something
you're not that's not familiar to you
just because you think oh it's Daniel
said this is what you have to do is how
you get in festival you make it this way
or some festival programmers said yeah
but if you film us to be great and
inherently good anyway it doesn't matter
about genre or style whatever is also
the film is just be good and a good film
comes from someone who believes in their
story is passionate about the story they
make any film that's won our festival
and won awards they're not films that
were just made with like little blase
effort this is not happening these films
were dedication our spam money lost and
you know a belief in the story also
understanding the story they're trying
to tell because they have a grasp on it
they're really passionate about what
they wrote many times the filmmakers in
the short space are a lot of times not
every time of course not but a lot of
times is a writer director you know
that's the same person right so if you
wrote the script you know the material
you should know well if you didn't write
it then you believe in it strongly that
you say hey I want to team up with you
and I want to make this film and I can
director your writing I could direct
your story you know but you have to have
that that passion and belief because you
don't have that you're just going to
fail the film won't be good there will
be areas where it will falter people
will know that you know they're not
you're not someone to follow because if
you're directing a group of people the
same way you're managing someone or
coaching or all those areas if if you're
talking to your the players and they
know you're talking out of your ass and
you don't believe what you're saying and
you're giving a half-ass effort they
know it they sense it and not gonna
fight for you they're not gonna play
for you they're not gonna care same way
is in crew and actors if you want
someone to give you their all as an
actor especially with the actors they're
passionate they trying to give
themselves to you whether it's emotional
stuff whether it's a break down scene or
you know it's a fight scene it's a
couple arguing and they're you know
they're having a real issue time they're
married couple in the movie they're two
actors are not married they're actors
they have to you have to believe that
they're there that there's a married
couple in there fighting and they got to
get it out of you got to get it out of
them and how do you do that if they
don't like you at all or they don't
believe in what you're trying to do or
how you're trying to direct them or the
story you're trying to tell or just how
you operate like if you don't really
they don't feel your belief in passion
for what the story is and the movie
being made they're just gonna give a
half-ass effort and it's not gonna be
good and or they gonna want to get out
of there and just knock the lines out
and go home you're like you know I'm
done with this project I don't care this
is not for me it is not good enough for
me or whatever whatever and just get it
over with
so that that's a big thing it's really
and it sounds simple and obvious but
it's not always the case a lot of people
might do a lot of things half-assed I
don't believe in what they're doing or
or I think they do but don't really or
they in this case when it comes to
storytelling maybe they just want to try
to impress and make a story that's not
their own or not something that they
believe in because they don't know the
material well enough or they don't
understand the nature of what they're
trying to tell with that story then a
problem showing you know it'll see
whether it's even a writing flower if it
is a story about I went back to now G of
sports right what if it's a basketball
story in and it makes no sense in in
terms of a basketball setting like the
writers understand basketball does like
basketball but they want to make a
basketball movie because someone's home
to do it or something and it's gonna
show that they don't know what the heck
they're talking about the story won't
make sense now as a viewer or watching
them over you're like oh you're watching
a scene of a basketball game and the
score makes no sense and it's not really
making any sense - what a an actual
supporting them would be like right like
if you know like it wouldn't make sense
then all of a sudden you're like this is
stupid this is a bad movie and they
don't understand the story they're
trying to tell them we know the sport
like you know if you're using analogies
for baseball or men for basketball like
things like that like keeping in the
basketball and the sports sports science
or the sports realm so yeah you know
really knowing and loving what you're
trying to do with the project is that
first and foremost is critical it's the
must and you'll see reflect and I go
back to the winners because if you're
winning the festival our festival others
he nominated for Oscars his films are
you know with with like a lack of
passion or effort or belief in the story
none of those filmmakers have made those
stories have gone that far made these
films you know just on some casual whim
let's just make this thing uh you know
shoot a one day knock it out and just
cram and who cares about detail okay
it's not that it's made with dedication
pass your time passion time and effort
all those things not to mention of
course talent other things you have to
have that so that's something the
biggest thing
how does someone get into a film
festival well it's obviously a big
sweeping statement there's a lot of ways
you know one ever gets the expected
we've talked about you know previously
is is you know obviously any Film
Festival most of course there are
festivals like anything else there's
good things bad things it's good
festival bad festivals but as a whole
you know you're looking to serve a
certain audience and you're looking to
showcase good films I mean that's just
the bottom line
so that sort of is one answer that's
already being served right I mean we're
just saying if the film's not good
you're not gay and so there's the
obvious part of that I know what that
means it's subjective good or bad but
within that there's things like of
course people talk a lot about runtime
alright for us for shorts for forty
minutes or less the film 40 minutes
gonna get in you know people make
sweeping statements oh well no way you
get in if it's too long that's not true
there are plenty of films that I've
gotten in that are very long there's in
the documentary one of the documentaries
is nominated is uh as forty minutes
basically
so that film made our festival got in
and got nominated and all these thing
and it's 40 minutes so to say a forty
minute film and make a sweeping
statement they won't get into festivals
or it's too long it's not exactly true
that said there are nuanced the things
it doesn't make it harder if your film
is longer you're competing in a
different sandbox kind of like you're
going up against other films with a
similar length and if there are so many
films that are that long only so many
can make the festival that are submitted
so you can't program a whole entire
festival if we program the whole
festival with films that are 30 to 40
minutes Oh we'd slash our films in half
so now we're only accepting 180 to 200
films maybe nominees were just dropping
a whole slew of filmmakers and talented
filmmakers and films 200 are gone just
because we decide we want to show
everything that's longer and most of
those films that are longer at times can
be sort of gratuitous or the length
maybe the films are too long I need to
be cut down they don't need to be that
long and there's is there's extraneous
scenes and things that don't need to be
there or there's stuff that's that drags
out or maybe the credits are way too
long so movies we will see that five
six-minute credit sequences that's for a
short that's insane
so you see that okay that shouldn't be
the case but some films need the length
they are like they need to be that long
so it's not just about slashing the the
runtime or cutting a film out
just because you feel you know oh yeah
well it needs to be shorter cuz
festivals tell me too well what the film
needs to be along what if it really
works for what it is we made plenty of
films are amazing films that are won
awards have been selected that 37
minutes 35 minutes 33 minutes our
winning film two years ago was 32
minutes 32 32 33 win that ballpark it
was over 30 minutes won the festival
that short Grand Prix long film and it
wasn't necessarily a fast pace was very
steady and slow but very well
thought-out it was it was a brilliant
film but it was the length it should
have been if they cut ten minutes out of
that maybe it doesn't win at all it
probably doesn't even get in maybe they
cut out too much and if the film doesn't
work it just for the sake of runtime so
it is always the the tricky argument
with the one time issue it's it's tough
but if a film is longer than you are
sort of narrowing your chances to some
degree because of the amount of time you
have left to be programmed so there is a
there is a truth to that but like
everything else is a gray area it's if
the film's meant to be that longer just
that awesome and amazing and we were
blown away by we're not gonna say no to
it just because it's long like that's
that we're gonna accept the film and
find a way to work around that that's
just what we're gonna do so there's that
part so you have to always look into
that and then of course you talk about
the different areas if a film that I
think the biggest thing to keep it
shorter is acting acting is a huge deal
I we were talking about it I was talking
with you about this yesterday too many
films have all the right things going
and that acting is just awful or really
poor and yes everything again is
subjective right but there is a an area
that's not really I mean bad acting is
backing you can tell the lines are me
deliver well and not hitting there's no
chemistry with the actors it's just it's
very poor and it you can't it stands out
like no other like it's just it kills
movie it just destroys the movie like at
that point you're done audience will not
forgive that they will feel like they're
watching something that's awkward
they'll feel comfortable and they'll
know right away okay this isn't this
isn't up to standard
so how are we gonna exhibit that in a
professional setting and I say
professional sense of we're in Hollywood
so we're showcasing for Hollywood top
executives industry people that energy
peers all that stuff other celebrities
whatever so there's all these people in
the audience that are watching the film
and and there
expecting a koala certain quality a
certain level and tear and then the
acting is just poor it's done this is
done so that I think is a huge huge
killer for many many shorts is whether
it's casting friends not using a casting
director not having a professional
assist in that process just thinking
they can handle it all because of course
times and this realm of world we're in
with the shorts of the director takes on
too much it's hard if to take on
everything yes you get the budget you
have to get the money you have to now
cast people you have to actually get the
crew together and get people you need
know and hire all these things you got
to do that's a lot of work that's
already overwhelming not having a
casting person help is tough cos you
start getting friends hey let's give
this buddy in that buddy I like you guys
you're great you're cool I like you do
my movie with me
okay well that isn't the u.s. service
because if they're not good we're you
don't even vet them whatever you think
okay they're our buddy in Hollywood yeah
I heard they can act you know I you know
that you did a play okay so maybe you're
not that's great that's cool hey let's
do this film just come shoot this thing
you shoot it yeah I don't got money to
pay okay let's do it
all right well fine but then now what if
that person is terrible
and I'll fire them I mean do you do at
that point whether your money's gone you
spent a few thousand bucks during the
weekend or one shoot day and it's $5,000
down the drain then what so you see that
a lot of this is friend sort of friend
casting situation and we've had people
talking panels about that he just can't
do it it's it's too important of what
you're trying to do too important to
make a great film and make something
that's really really good it really
reflects on your work to just say hey I
want to just pass this on to people
casually because I think they're cool
and come be my movie you can't do it
like that's just I just it doesn't work
here for this isn't that this isn't a
you know situation where there's
automatic abuse in feature film or
something where you know they're gonna
be bad there's a whole world of B cinema
and bad movies that meant to be that or
movies that are just bad because it's a
market for a star selling overseas and
the movie stink but they sell that's not
the world here we're in the world of
it's critical we have to be really good
and you're trying to showcase yourself
to get to a certain level so you can't
play with that it's it's very important
so it's a big thing obviously it's
important where you have you know
Scimitar ofey and and all the other
factors and you know and editing and all
these things are all critical of course
too but if all that's there and acting
is bad and it's like
done and so all the work that's been
done that's great a DP can be brilliant
and everything a visual look great or
the good visual effects the acting
stinks you know they're representative
of your movie like they're there it's
it's just there it's everything so I
think if you do way what's the most
important it's obviously a little unfair
to say it's the most important but I
kind of would argue that it kind of is
and I grant all things equal not saying
of course if lighting is poor and as DP
is terrible in the movie shot really
poorly yeah of course that's same kind
of thing it's it's not gonna make it
right but if all equal acting just
stands out that bad for the wrong
reasons it's no chance so that's I think
that's a I think if it's one thing when
a pinpoint for all the I would say that
that's a big thing so what's happening
with the Oscars and Holly shorts yeah
well it's uh it's been a pretty we've
been now qualifying for three years so
there's our third year coming up there
we're an Oscar qualifying festival so
what that means is our grand prize
winning film for the last two years has
been automatically qualified for the
Academy Award consideration so it
started three years ago and now that now
that's also kicked up this year with two
out of categories so now this year the
grand prize winning film will still be
qualified likelike last few years like
always but we've also added a best short
live-action that category that winner
for our festival will also be qualified
so not only just the grand prize winner
but short live-action winner will also
be qualified and then best animation so
no animation category is also covered by
our festival so so this year coming up
2019 those three winners of those
categories will be qualified for the
Oscars so now we have more films that
have a chance to be nominated so instead
of having our grand prize winning film
that's great one film right there now we
actually have three films have a chance
to be nominated so that's very exciting
for us and of course exciting for the
filmmakers so for us more reason why the
value of the submission is there so you
win those categories you now qualified
now when the qualification happens then
those films are qualified now we're in
the pool at the Oscar judges in the jury
review the film's to select which films
get shortlisted and then after that
which films get qualified and actually
nominate I mean so they're nominated so
so this year we had well let me go back
two years ago short live-action category
had three of the five films so three of
the five films two years ago were were
nominated and the winner
silent child was our one of our films so
the winning films from Howie Schwartz
two of the other ones were from our
was well and our best director for my
nephew Emmett also know nominated as
well and watching what this so that film
as well so two of those films were
winners of our festival the one that
didn't win actually at our festival won
the Oscar so it says a lot about the
competition the quality was really cool
to have three or five for that category
for live-action last year this year we
have one film in every category so we
have a short live-action with skin which
is exciting because that film skin won
our festival so it was qualified by us
so we feel sort of a very passionate
about this film we love the filmmakers
love the film the story I think it's a
fantastic film we believed it I felt
very early on when I first saw it I'm
recalling Thea I was like look you gotta
watch this right away and I felt very
strong that this film was gonna be
something I just knew I just I don't
know just felt really strong about it
just felt I had a real chance to be
something and it's cool to see that
process come through because you believe
in something you say hey this is I just
see it you see you watch it you feel I
felt strong about it just made me kind
of jump out of my seat like oh this is
something I got a call about right now
we got to come because I said I'll watch
this movie we're gonna talk about it he
watched the right away we talked we
really strongly feel great about it or
accepting it this film's gonna get in
this is one they just just sort of blew
everyone away
so then goes and festival jury loves it
as well unanimous and wins the Best
Short so it was it was really really
really well taken by the jury which is
rare to see there's sometimes a debate
and think this was one of these films I
just you know I'm seeing kind of loved
and to have that qualification having
our festival thing go on to be nominated
it's very exciting for us so we really
feel good about skins chances and
they're really happy for them to be
nominated is pretty cool and then we
also have some weekends in animation
category that also nominated as well and
that was a finalist on our festival last
year and then a documentary lifeboat you
know about the refugee situation and
it's really amazing film and then that
film also also nominate as well so dock
animation and live-action those three
categories we have a film in each and
also we have one other dock that wasn't
the festival last year but the filmmaker
is a past best director winner so in
alumni that she is now also nominated
for her documentary period end of
sentence so that film was also nominated
so it's kinda like we really have four
films of all the cual the nominated
films this year which is really neat so
and they're also in each category so
what if we went all three that knew
pretty awesome if all three of those one
that would be the grand slam I'll be
really incredible of all those films won
Oscars I do
so so very excited that as years of one
on I mean early years the festival we
didn't have many films that were
nominated it just wasn't you know we
weren't there yet the level of quality
the the the competition aspect the
qualification aspect that we weren't
qualified so we didn't have that going
on then in years past eight nine years
and your ten we started to get more
films that were nominated and winning
Oscars we were started seeing hey these
films are here too we should be
qualifying like we're our level of
quality is there on par with the Oscar
stuff so that's when we started the
process of application and all that and
now being qualified and seeing that the
films winning like skin having that
direct relation of winning and then
going on to be actually nominated and
all that is exciting it's like now that
there's a direct effect of seeing the
the line of winning at the festival and
going on to be nominee is so to see that
many films now and all the categories
covered it's pretty cool so it's been a
growth to see not just one film here and
there but now I have three four or five
films each year in the pool of being
nominated and some of the winning is
it's really awesome so you know again
part of that growth and and and
strengthen the festival and seeing that
you know go to court efficient and and
that happened now and then hopefully
just obviously continues and too long
ago all the films will be from the
festival that'd be pretty cool of all
nominated films will be from Holly
shorts but you know we're happy to see
that that number is going up and up
every year so it's been pretty cool to
see that that growth and and now be
qualifying and seeing the films you know
the Oscars is pretty awesome you used to
work in distribution you had a day job
before you did all those shows how did
that help you it helped a lot it helped
a lot
well for one distribution is a obviously
well not just distribution theatrical
distribution so dealing with theaters
right so in the theater world I'm
learning a theater business as a
festival we are in the theater business
we are renting theaters we're booking
theaters in our case we're using the
Chinese Theater so we're booking them we
have a contract you know rates how does
it work like we're understanding the
business so me knowing the business
better understanding what theater is my
charge for this stuff what a booking
means you know how it works when they
book films and their theaters knowing
that part of the business understanding
when I'm taking a screen with a festival
what it means for them to lose a
theatrical film from a studio I
understand that process so now I can
understand better what the rates are
what kind of business they're gonna do
with that screen for that week if we
weren't there
all that kind of stuff now I understand
that so I can go back to the theater and
they say hey this is gonna cost us this
much to rent this theater for a week I
said well no I know if you were playing
X movie and you'd make this much for
this week in this theater now I can
understand that part of the business I
know those numbers and that can actually
better kind of fight the good fight for
our sort of right to have a good cost of
the theater and not be like gouged by a
theater or they can just overcharge us
and take advantage of us as a festival
right that part helps a lot so
understand the business that way and
learning also client relations it's
different than of course zone with
filmmakers and filmmaker relations but
every event every business every
everything is is client relations
whether you're salesman whether you're
film festival dealing with filmmakers
whether I'm a salesman at theatrical
distribution selling movies the theaters
and I'm literally selling it for
Lionsgate and selling movies to the to
the theaters I have to understand how to
negotiate how to deal with customers the
shooting process they the good and bad
how to deal with personalities like all
those things that had to deal with on a
weekly basis I think we definitely
helped strengthen my understanding of
the festival how to how to better try to
find ways to listen and serve filmmakers
and our customers things like that like
that's always gonna be valuable so
definitely that was a big part of it so
the business learning with distribution
was big understanding the theatrical
business for the festival we are
directly related to theaters so that was
a big help you know and then of course
learning how to deal with customers it
kind of had a how to sell yourself how
to sell you know some of the films we
had were let's be honest sometimes I'm
afraid good so you got to sell these
films to people and really upsell films
that weren't very good and so you learn
how to sell in any situation and for us
we learn how to you know promote and
push and sell our festival and believe
in and do that so I think there's a lot
a lot of good that came from it and and
in the hustle I mean it was like two
jobs what's the job so I was working
there day and night was work it was
stayed working at Lionsgate at nighttime
work on the festivals and as it was both
lunch break working the festival to
calls and emails during the lunch all
this stuff was constant so definitely
you had to appreciate the hustle on the
grind you know that was like we had to
really work at it and it kept you on
your toes yeah it was a lot it was a lot
of a lot of a lot of volume of things I
deal with from emails from all side
workwise stuff and then of course Holly
Schwartz emails and things like that so
time to watch films it was you know
you're working all day and you gotta
watch at night so or you got a weekend
Zee weekends were crammed we could get
together and watch all these movies so
we were just constantly working so it
was it was a little it was a lot a lot
of time spent working all areas whether
it's festival were or you know Lionsgate
stuff and also the last part of it was
just you're in the business we're in the
middle of the business in the trenches
I'm seeing what films are being sold was
films we're selling how much they go for
all these different things the aspect of
what we sold the films for all that kind
of stuff you learn about you know so now
I also know who the players are I'm just
doing what you know who executives are
our different studios and things like
that so so for panels the industry
people for judges it was great resource
to like hey I'm saying with the honesty
pull from some people like hey you want
to come and do a panel you wanted I do
this festival as well this is what I do
this is I'm here but I'm also doing
Holly shorts this is what I do this is
my my thing so you know it was a it was
a way to sort of you know I guess do
both and how to pull from it and so that
was kind of uh I guess that's what
chameleon that way it was kind of just
trying trying to extract some of that
you know and I was able to do that had
access so it was good
starting out did you think it was going
to become such a hustle I mean I know
that right now that's like this really
like people thrive on that word because
it seems like cool I'm doing but I mean
it's all I'm sure you were exhausted at
times yeah did you realize that it would
be so much work because there's so many
people I'm sure that would love to
emulate what you've done but yeah you
tell me yeah I don't I don't I don't
yeah I don't know if I I guess if you're
saying like it would I've like look back
it's a okay 24 whatever 20 through every
year you know and we're gonna we just
said let's do this we're gonna do this
and obviously didn't know what that next
15 years would mean and how much work
that would have been I mean I don't know
I honestly can say I don't know it's not
something I said yeah you know I've
always actually yeah do it all over
again you know well yeah I mean yes I
love what we're doing and are very
passionate about it I'm very very
excited and happy that we've been able
to grow this way so I'm proud of it so I
guess the answer is definitely yes but
definitely all that said it would it's
also something to realize like I did not
also know and I can't sit here and say I
knew that was gonna be that much work
and that volume I never knew we're gonna
you know thousands of thousand
submissions how would I have known that
like to ever think that we were gonna
get six thousand like I never would have
known that
like would even imagine that right so
what that means to actually how much
time you spent watching all those movies
all those years and then my twenties
like watch look I never would have
imagined that would've been that way so
that's something that was unexpected
I was the wrong word it's not unexpected
I mean you wanted to grow we were hoping
to grow when we knew that there's a
certain level like hey Sundance consis
many films so we have to try to then we
understood there was a growth projection
and we knew there's more films to watch
and we'd have to watch a lot of films
but it's also on us to how we handled it
because we know other festivals do
things where they just hire a bunch of
interns they you watch this stuff we
don't watch anything it would just kind
of take the best and whatever like
that's is what they do and that's not
something we were we haven't did a
review team thing like this until
recently like because we had to it
wasn't it wasn't a thing of almost for
the choice like before was always just
us watching everything all the time no
no holds barred no questions asked
that's just also we chose to do it that
way too so it was also a choice so it's
not a victim thing we're yeah we didn't
it was overwhelming we also chose to do
with this what we chose to have it be
this way and as a passion thing for us
to stay together were childhood friends
we grew up together it's like family
everyone getting together in the
weekends all this stuff and getting
together for meeting it was part of our
way to I guess so constantly or
something I imagine there's some part of
it was also part of us doing something
that we felt we could all stick together
right you know like grew up together and
that kind of thing we have that kind of
relationship and friendships and things
it it did help you keep kept the
connection going right cuz if we didn't
do it right if there's no harsh words
ever existed well we've spent too much
time together and as much calls and
chats as much as we've had all these
years I'm just speaking out so I guess
for just myself and Theo there's others
involved but I answer's no it would be
no and so that was something that it's
kind of cool and you look back and think
okay maybe you know there's also the
personal connection realization or
reason for all this it's you know it's
it's not something you can ignore it's
something that's that's probably part of
the whole thing so I guess all that long
with an answer and that's a yeah I guess
I go back to it I'd say the key I would
do it all over again yes who would and
I'm very excited that it's it's grown at
this point and very proud now yeah I
think it's really neat and but I never
would have imagined it though I even
know you say you did or you think you
could try to fish I don't know if it
would've gotten to this point like that
how do I know I thought I would've known
and it's not something we were like
naive to say we
would have happened it's no this is not
possible 15 years working two jobs
emails constant work where is it in you
that still wants to discover like these
great films like where does that passion
come from well it's also the excitement
of watching anything right like it's
like the cool thing about it is I mean
like okay like if you watch go to the
movies now I say we go I go to Arclight
right now after this is done we go to
our clang go watch a movie I know what
I'm getting into basically right I mean
I kind of have an idea what the movies
are I know who the cinema I know the
stars I have a general idea with the
movies not much is going in blindly I've
seen the trailers we've heard about the
movies rave reviews whatever
well these films I don't know anything
about anything about anyone I don't know
who they are now not everyone because
alumni that resubmit and I'm familiar
with their work and that kind of stuff
okay outside of that right like the
assignment on that is like it's sort of
like a it's essentially kind of opening
a gift every time you don't know what
you're getting you open the box here's a
gift I have no idea where you're giving
me I open it up it could be a really
awesome gift or could be an ugly sweater
like this sucks my aunt to give me other
bad gift and here's okay then it's bad
but if it's awesome and you're like this
this is the cool I didn't know I never
thought you'd get me this I never
thought this is like it's like this it's
a gift it's like the coolest thing it's
it's hard to describe like it's you
could you excited if you love movies if
you like this kind of thing if you don't
and it's who cares you're like this is
boring but if you think it's cool or
excited about it it's like a it's and
yeah like the thing with skin like we
saw skin and Washington I was like that
it just it just had it it just I don't
know you just see it you're excited and
it just it gets us excited and we're
calling each other like to whatever kids
all giddy like it's just it's just what
it is it's just a fun part of it that's
do you have to enjoy it look at the fun
of it like that's the but a second
adventure you don't know what we're
gonna get we watch all these movies all
these hours and you can spend we had
days where we spent the whole day and
not one movie we like that movie would
not one movie got any we even watch
sometimes in 75 movies and hundred
movies you spent a whole day from
morning to night late night all the way
the whole damn day and nothing's good
like this that gets like beating you
does nothing and then you get this one
movie and it's like that was amazing
you're so excited just gives you like a
juice energies like whoa and it just
hits you it could spend the whole day
eighty movies whatever and you finally
get that one movie so one movie of all
those movies even makes the festival but
that movie is like blows you away you're
so excited
there now you're like I get the chance
to meet these people I get to interact
with them like this there's a you have a
connection like you get to find out more
maybe about the movie like that's always
still gonna be cool and I guess if
that's not cool and that falls off and
it's not cool anymore not exciting then
yeah that's time stop then it's done
right because if it's not engaging or
exciting we're not like ecstatic to see
those films and then get to meet them or
get involve that process or having them
be part of the family or all the things
that go into acceptance the festival is
showing and screening and all the other
things then it's done but for now it's
still it's still there you still get
still get excited it's like yeah it's
pretty cool like it's again you don't
know we don't go in reading a bunch of
stuff I don't like to read too much of
the snobs doesn't you say I just want to
watch the film put it on let's see the
movie I don't want to know all these
things it isn't it's not about that it's
about the movie how does it stand up do
you love the movie to enjoy it is it
really good you see the certain
qualities that are there you know all
those things is really cool so you get
that level excitement like it's it's
it's harder what else can replicate that
in life right like it's not too many
things where you can just put something
on and all of a sudden you never know
what might might come of that so this is
cool surprise element to every movie you
watch there's thousands of them but you
don't know what you're gonna see with
every movie because again it's not a
marketed where I know what they are it's
not a green book where I'm gonna go see
the movie I see the trailer ten times
I've heard of reviews and stories and
black back and forth about it's not that
this is like I don't know pretty much
any of it outside of maybe already
seeing it another vessel or something
like that or whatever or knowing the
alumni and that kind of thing it's like
this whole complete surprise so yeah I
think I think that's probably a pretty
good idea I think the idea of the gift
or the box you don't know what you gonna
open you open that thing up you know or
you know it's it's just it's cool so
it's and it's so exciting so it makes us
realize hey this is so exciting for us
and it still we can still do this and if
it's not then we got a problem because
if it's something we don't we're not
happy about it giddy about are excited
about or passionate about then at that
point if that happens I have to find out
how the pass is honored whatever cuz it
be over what's the first movie you saw
in the theater as a kid first movie was
Goonies you remember where was well I
think I do but I think I'm wrong
I always thought it was a Chinese
Theatre which is funny right because oh
yeah so that's also apartment I don't
think it's actually totally accurate I
think it might actually have been I
think I might have been the South Coast
Plaza house that's my mom he's good I
think I actually have accurate I think
I'm actually that might be right and I
think the Chinese eater is wrong and I
probable that I'm ahead a little more
than you know because I know I went to
the Chinese Theater very early in life
and saw one of my early movies I think
it was et there
ET Goonies one of them but I know
Goonies was first yeah I just got I got
to talk my mom more about that because I
always thought it was that but now I
thought about a recent I was kind of
wondering about it I wonder because we
at one point in that run that time were
living in Orange County
Irvine so more reasonable to think we
would have been at South Coast Plaza
watching a movie then at that time the
Chinese Theater which we'd go to when we
were in LA at some times and and when we
visited later in the years it's common
early 80s I lived in Southern California
but not always LA brief time in LA is in
Orange County so we did go to Chinese
Theater but I got a double check the
time frame a time lapse of I mean the
time range of when I saw what or what
movies were at the Chinese here because
I remember recalling the Chinese Theatre
very early and seen one of my early
first movies but I always thought it was
their first and I don't know hundred
percent sure but hey it's cool to think
it's actually a pretty cool thing early
on I was just going to check he was a
kid so young we went there and I
remembered I do remember scene the
fugitive at the TCL that you will back
then the Romans you know I remember that
was cool we were visiting LA and in the
summer good to see the movie that was
just a big box office hit and you know
was singing at the Chinese Theater so I
see those movies there and all this
stuff over the years and go to that
theater and then so the years later have
a festival there and be there for only
nine so it's a cool full circle thing
that again you got appreciate these
things I mean it's life it's cool its
unique who knows you know the hell knows
I never would have thought I've been
doing this stuff so I think you never
really know so it's it's nice to have
this moment to say you know what this is
pretty neat so it's pretty cool to
appreciate that because you never would
have known we never were known that that
would happened and all these years later
that we would have been doing this stuff
and also be at the theater
we're when it's kids and I like that
it's pretty cool so you know again
loving movies and being a fan of movies
and all that if the appreciate these
things is kind of a little geek moments
yeah but it's pretty neat but yeah it's
um yeah those are those early classics
were
so in movies I remember as a kid
who's buying short films today well now
that's obviously the ever-changing sort
of question right now right I mean with
with the new streaming platforms through
apps the development and discussion
about short content short films where
the place of short films is in this sort
of sort of new world of streaming is
like sort of the great unknown it's
something we're excited about because we
think there's great potential for shorts
to be its own big market and I think
it's something that we're trying to get
behind and really excited about outside
of obviously the big question or sort of
the broad answer there are specific
companies that are looking for content
short content we work with a few of them
and one of them is dust they look for
sci-fi films so there are specific
content they're looking for is sci-fi so
we're sci-fi adventure you know the kind
of realm of science fiction be a tech
VFX and things like that but they're
looking for those films so we like to
talk with them and work with them all
the time we love a great film hey we
have a great sci-fi film here take a
look you know they like it they could
acquire known exclusive you know so
their deals are fair and you get more
exposure so it's kind of win-win for
everyone and they also have a company I
don't know if it's sister company or
just their other streaming companies
alter and alternates horror films so
their focus is more horror thriller and
so they're both obviously genre based
but really cool areas of distribution
opportunities for for filmmakers looking
for that and getting exposure and
actually getting acquired now again in
all exclusive way so they're not taking
your film and taking the IP or really
anything like that so you know it's
definitely an opportunity for filmmakers
to get more exposure and I have another
place to to get distribution and of
course everyone knows shorts TV short
Stevie's been doing it a long time so
they're always acquiring shorts and
they're linear on DirecTV and AT&T and
all that stuff universe so they're on
television and so that's their area our
angle and they're always looking for
shorts all the time so they've but
they've been doing it for a while but
they're now in the streaming aspect the
streaming aspect you've seen companies
like the dust and stuff and then you
have crunchyroll does anime so there's
all these different sort of at the
moment apps that are focus apps are web
sites focused on indirect direct markets
right so anime crunchyroll sci-fi dust
you know things like that um you know
there's the coop TV app they do horror
as well so there's always different apps
and websites that are focused on certain
genres or styles of film that are
looking to acquire shorts all different
deals and different things as far as
exclusivity you're known as
but now that that's a that's a big deal
like this is something that's this
ever-changing growing this wasn't this
this wasn't the way 5 10 15 years ago
this is you know when we started there
was nothing there was there lino
Schwartz distribution there was no none
of it so there was no opportunity for
Schwartz they didn't have any place in a
distribution landscape and now there's
there's I'm just naming a few there's so
many more that are doing this it's it's
pretty well to think of what can come
you know their stuff focus on certain
genres and there's there's also apps are
looking for just general short content
and and ever-changing we have our own
platform we're looking to build up and
work on and it's called bit pics so bit
pics TV is our website in our app we're
on Amazon and Roku looking to grow that
right now it's just a general Schwartz
sort of landscape we have short small
type of genres and everything that we
have sort of best of fest and things
from the monthly screenings and films we
like we have on the on the platform in
subscription-based and so that's
something that we're looking to grow and
take the next level it's something
that's not at that place yet where it's
huge and well-known and you know
universally know you know worldwide and
things like that or you know but that's
something we feel they can get there and
shorts of a huge market because
worldwide people like watching shorts
India China Europe Europe they love
shorts so now if you have a place where
everyone can focus on one area to go to
you know you think of hey I want to
stream certain TV shows whatever you
think Netflix now what about shorts if
we have the place that everyone says hey
want to go to a bit pace for shorts that
would that be amazing they can find all
the best shorts in the world they can
find them there you know that's
something that we're exploring you know
and and it's something I think the
audience is now there more than ever
because again TVs are not TVs anymore
it's your phone you can literally sit in
your phone and watch stuff anywhere you
are and it's something that young
generations are not doing so we're all
trying to figure how to capitalize on
this and make this be the next thing so
maybe our filmmakers or short content
creators can make more money can have
their shorts made and you get a bigger
audience than just really cool festivals
are some some eyeballs and some
streaming sites and stuff would be
recognized worldwide you know in a
different way
and I really do think that this is where
things are going I think in the next
five to ten years it's gonna be a big
change in shift for what the perception
of shorts is we talked about earlier
what a short films me what is what it
would
and then 15 years ago yeah it was just
hey you made a cool thesis film or art
film to try to show it a festival now
that's what it was and you know it's
just strictly a calling card that film
could make you any money that film
couldn't be its own thing
not on that now there's so many places
in Havanese of ways a short can go
whether it's attribution whether it's it
is a calling car whether it's a short to
be a feature whether it's TV series
whether it's you just make great shorts
and that's all you do is make awesome
shorts and that's what you do you don't
have to necessarily just be hey I made a
short to go to be to go make a feature
film or to showcase myself know you can
make great shorts and tell short stories
in a way that can be your calling card
in that way not like just to go on here
something else so this whole world with
all these different apps and platforms
that are looking for films I mean I
wouldn't make some money than we're
gonna get more exposure it's just it's
huge I mean it's it's definitely
something that I mean this is changed
the whole landscape of what we're doing
and that's why we even see more
submissions not only the growth of
festival but the fact that more people
are making short films than ever before
in the world that's just this is a fact
so it's really exciting I mean you have
those platforms there's they know does
their staff pick so you have Vimeo
static for exposure and they do that
there's a short of the week and that
website and you know they do that so
short of the week is a place where they
pick out their short expose them and
give you a sort of stamp of approval for
your film they do that and that's really
cool so you have these different sites
and whether it's sites whether it's apps
that they're looking for content so now
not only just m-80s doing contests all
time looking for content you know
they've done promotions with us and so
18t is looking for stuff for their
channels all the time for TV they're
looking for shorts and they're doing
contests for short filmmakers to give
them prizes like it's just sort of this
new Wild West new world like there's
actually opportunities to not just
showcase yourself with make money and
also get Garner's more exposure than
ever before which is really cool I mean
it's to be part of that there's
something we couldn't have foreseen back
then but now as we position ourselves as
a strong festival and things in the
short space we want to see how we can
push this thing further and grow you
know the online and capability in the
app capability and off the festival all
of it to grow it to new heights and and
to just make short films the new sort of
new premiere content you know I think
there's a there's a chance and I think
that's pretty cool and I think that's
something that definitely
you know next 5-10 years we're gonna see
keep changing you said earlier that
sometimes you'll see a billboard or
something and you'll go oh I wonder
whose film that is and then you'll look
at it's a Holley shorts alum and it
makes you proud are there any great
stories that you can tell us or or do
you have alums come back to you and say
you know this festival really helped put
me on the map yeah I know there's
definitely definitely a lot I mean it's
it's the point now we were just just two
days ago driving down sunset and and
looks alright at stoplights he'll
billboard and and for the show MILF and
then the Frankie Shaw's and alumni
really go there she's on the billboard
that's her and Frankie Schell was at her
festival three years ago with her film
and there's one there and then I Drive
down and we can go further up and then
there's a little poster of his horror
film that's coming out and oh it's
Nicholas McCarthy's filming it he's
another alumni and I'm just seeing
billboards and people just it's like
it's kind of wild to think that that's
happening now because that wasn't early
on it wasn't that way even though as we
established you're nine you're ten we
had a lot of great alumni but ten now
it's like it's everywhere it's pretty
neat to see hey I go to a movie and I'm
looking at credits and I see the editor
of this movie is this person oh they're
alumni from this year they did this film
and I'm always looking to see who's to
know what it's kind of my cuz I'm
watching all the films and programming
and I always have to pay attention to
every single person involved and so Theo
jokes that on the IMDB you've Holly
short like you know what's going on so
I'm seeing it cuz it's part of the jobs
for to understanding who's doing what
after the fact where they're going where
their careers going what are they up to
next who are they working with all that
research of just watching films going
just to go into a theater to watch a
movie to see who's doing what who's
involved in the film if it's their film
or are they working on the film you know
what ties them I have the festival you
know all that stuff is replacing to all
of it it's important to know what's
going on with the business but it's also
exciting that we now have alum alumni
doing just huge things where those TV
shows you know show runners creating
their own series directing big feature
film studio films it's commercial
directing all this stuff like it's just
we've seen this kind of alumni explosion
over the years I mean it's not just X
it's also 15 years right I mean if
someone did a year film in year three
ten years later it stands a reason if
they're good talented they're young
maybe they're in their 20s now their 30s
they've established themselves they work
their way up they're going to be doing
more things right like so as time has
gone on obviously we're older so with
the age comes experience so those
filmmakers have also grown with it but I
mean it's just the
I couldn't even write along all the
names just indifferent I'm it but
there's some that are obvious as people
like ISA ray who's been at the festival
their webseries and we'd spoke about
webseries earlier but obviously her
famous webseries turn into a hit show
now and now she's no she's a superstar I
mean she's on fire shows a hit she's
starring in all that movie she's doing
everything so she's like on fire so we
have alumni on that level where people
know who they are recognizable then we
have people who are doing films that are
maybe it's more quiet you don't know
them as much as a sort of household
names but but they're doing amazing work
and getting film's theatrical released
and we're working on series and TV shows
and it's you know it's it's just it's
cool to see social media that way cuz
I'm looking on posts and I'm just seeing
people post about their stuff all the
time and it's kind of like I'll have to
keep up on who's not face of posting
about what they're doing what they're
feeling they're working on what did what
TV episode they directed her it's crazy
I mean Dave Rodriguez directing all
types of TV shows cat carros he's
directing TV shows all the time like
that they were in our alumni from the
years of like Oh eight oh nine another
now they're fully established TV
directors who are doing great work who
were just in the biz working like it's
just cool to see that that shift and
they do come back a lot of alumni submit
future films being short films we
obviously see you filmmakers make more
films you know cuz you do they make one
short they never make it short again
so we sing a lot of continuous films
come back filmmakers make more films and
submit more and more work to us so it's
really cool to see a lot of love and I
come back submit their work and some are
great some could still get in and get
accepted and he don't I mean last year
we had I believe it was around 500
alumni submitted films pretty crazy so
obviously that stands the reason that
many cannot get in just based on the
fact that 400 accepted so we're not
gonna it's already right there they're
competing in a different sort of sort of
set of circumstances to competing as
themselves kind of Greg accepting all
films at all its alumni base and just
that's all we're doing that would make
any sense so it's um so there are
sometimes people talk about oh if you're
in the festival your alumni you're gonna
get in it's not really accurate it's not
obvious it's not possible it's not
something we're gonna do it's not
accurate it's still about the film about
the next film about to work and that's
really what it boils down to now
obviously there's relationships and we
love our alumni but it's it's cool to
see that that that word amounts good how
many people come back to submit that's
really neat and also making more films
but yeah the list it's it's pretty
pretty awesome like the
list of alumni are things that they've
gone to do now early on we're hoping to
see who would kind of take off and that
kind of thing it was kind of like oh wow
someone but now it's sort of we can't
even keep up with them on filmmakers
doing really good work or having films
released or you know just selling
scripture whatever the case may be like
they're just deep pain TV shows and
think it's just incredible it's uh I
mean at this ticket people know I mean
carmen cabanas one she's doing amazing
work and working on arco isn't and she's
just was our festival year three and now
seeing her growth has been amazing so
it's yeah that's something we're very
proud of we bring back alumni to do
cherry work and things like that be on
the jury and it's pretty cool but yeah
we're we're we're very pleased and very
excited to see you know the the the
quality of work that lawmen are doing it
just is also keeps telling us that hey
right path the right films we're
hopefully doing the right job with who
we pick how we're curating the films and
what we see them do after the fact
that's pretty neat I mean yeah this many
years now with 15 if we're seeing it
it's it's like it's never been before
just seeing the really just an eye
popping over everywhere I drivers
Brittney I'm just driving down the
street and seeing different billboards
and things and people keep it's just
it's crazy i mean ii think that we need
to drive down the street and see posters
and stuff and we know who was involved
at different projects it's and they were
from our festival you know our last year
one filmmaker pulled me aside over a
night he was looking I love your
festival and back this year I'm really
proud and happy but it's got let you
know like when I was here years ago my
first film I screen and and it's this
executive pull me aside I want to talk
to me hired me to do all his commercial
were kind of doing Nike commercials and
campaigns and stuff and I worked with
this this production company to do
commercials and he's like it made me a
career like I've been working at this
and this is my career he's I still make
my films for my passion that's my work
but he's like this this gave me a queer
family I don't know the state of that
I'm like that's awesome that's amazing
that's just humbling I don't know what
else can I say I mean it's just like
he's oh we're gonna be proud of that
that's pretty neat so it was like that
was really cool yeah obviously I didn't
know that how would I've known that if
he didn't tell me I mean it you know
it's harder to know about commercials as
opposed to hey some was they want a
billboard or you know on a TV show
whatever but that was really neat so
that's the kind of stuff we like hearing
and and yeah it's really really awesome
when that happens it's a it's obviously
happening more and more so that's pretty
cool
I would imagine this comes up a lot I'm
wondering if I write Halle Schwartz a
letter and I tell them you know listen I
would love it if you could waive the fee
and I will do this this and this to
reciprocate for that money are you able
to then take my film and waive that fee
well my answer to that would be no yes I
we weren't we're not a UH
we're not a fan of the fee waiver
request many festivals maybe probably
really some festival maybe don't maybe
offer a lot of waivers now there are
some small instances of things like okay
if I say I do there really is only
instance if I go to a festival and I see
your film and I'm like I got to have it
I'm telling you I want like I'm
essentially at your door begging you for
your film then obviously in fairness I'm
telling you to submit it you know I
should either worst case offer your
discount war you know maybe away the fee
but they don't do that ever I don't ask
for films anymore we don't ask for films
really at all so it's really about to me
is name is just about the financial
aspect it's about the actual fairness of
the process if you feel your film is
worthy you're good enough for that well
many others are so why are we waving
just one fee just cuz you asked for it
and everyone else is paying full price I
mean what's the difference why should I
offer you this this this this nice gift
thing for what like what just to ask for
it is not a good enough reason and even
if there are sending stands the
situations or you know you we hear all
types of stuff whether it's the
financial stuff I know obviously
especially for student filmmakers
obviously a lot of times money is how
your student you're in college I
understand that for that part of it that
I get that but then you have to hand
pick what festival you trying to submit
to and and all this stuff and you got to
make a plan you know and as you gotta
just make something happen you can't
just say hey I want a favor cuz I'm
having some struggles or and we all have
struggles in life we all have things I
was in college and broke you had to pay
for certain things I wanted it to pay
for make it happen you don't just ask
for that because you feel you deserve it
and so maybe there is a certain element
of an offense it's offensive
in some ways to me I just don't
personally don't like it I'll try to
answer as many as I can't answer people
to justice Elms Handley we do not take
waivers and that's it at times if if
there are some circumstances where we
like the email feel like someone's
really making a good effort
real reason behind something or or
whatever I don't know or you know we can
always say look there are certain
situations where we have discounts or
promo partners and things and look them
up and if you see their promo thing and
they send the code out or you know you
have a discount out there you get a
discount but that's all we can do
yourself to pay because it's just the
principle of it
everyone's submitting and paying so in
the canoe get accepted you don't pay and
then they pay they're good money and
then you get in or they got in you know
why are you getting the same equal
benefit for a submission fee no so again
not that it's any every dollar counts
but we're not our fees aren't like you
know like you're you know something five
dollars to submit to a festival no it
adds up for a lot of festivals I get
that but our fee is what our fee is I
don't care what their festivals charge
or how many Fester's you're submitting
to for us we're looking at it as you
should submit to ours we feel it's in
that caliber and and it's in the range
of 35 to 70 or so dollars the range of
early to late if you submitted last day
it's obviously higher if it's spent that
right now early bird it's and you were
from 35 to 40 bucks it's not something
you need to take go donate blood for I
mean it's a it's not you know it's just
and then again I don't want to come
across as too flippant or anything I
just it's it's just to me it is
something that it takes a time from my
day or any of our day or or in terms of
assistance or anyone to answer these
emails to even at all which some of them
suppose you can't even catch up on or
sometimes we want almost wondering why
even bother answering like something
like do I have to answer you I don't
have to I mean you know but we are at
least trying to be kind enough to at
least get back to people said look we
don't offer waivers it's just it's just
something that isn't even a time thing
like oh it's early in later or depending
on what's the fee it's just it's not
something I feel the principle always
has been whyever is everyone else paying
and what makes you different than you
feel your speciality you don't have to
pay just based on you know either not
just struggle but hey I my films that
good and I just think it shouldn't and
that's also to touch on that that bugs
me even more people like the filmmaker
should never reference hey I played this
festival that festival so that means
obviously I'm at a certain place I got
in some festivals but now here way my
feet for this one okay let me ask you
this did you submit those festivals in
Bay yeah right yes you did I'm assuming
yes okay so now you're telling me my
festival is not worthy of submitting the
fee and paying you got any of those
festivals but then unis didn't like the
hypocrisy of that
bugs me to no end okay you're telling me
you played these fess already so
obviously we assumed you paid this
omission for yeah I highly doubt that
gave your waivers and at times I used to
get mad I would actually say other
people like also did you pay this fee
and no answer like it you paid their
fees so you're telling me now you're not
gonna pay our submission fee at a
moderate rate just because you just
played there already and now you just
don't want to pay our fee so now
obviously you not inherently notice how
how offensive that can be festival to
say you're telling me we played them
first we play with that you know hey
it's good to be personal you're telling
me you played there and paid there and
you don't want to pay for us
so you're saying well you ran out of
money now you don't want to pay or you
just don't to pay period and just your
and ask for something because you now
feel you have a sort of more special
thing going because you've been accepted
so it's great awesome that the films
come to us we know hey they made these
festivals is great all good but again
everyone else is paying so I just don't
I just you know now I know there are
circumstances of of you know other
countries like Iran comes up a lot they
cannot pay fees or there's sanctions for
credit cards and things that we hear
about I don't know the political
situation quite frankly of how much that
is fully accurate or not I believe it is
to be we still get submissions from Iran
at times and they pay I don't know how
they do it I don't know what but they
come in and they do and then those that
don't then we get emails from we get
emails from there every day probably
five emails a day maybe ten that's some
free waivers and I just I can't open the
floodgates there if I say yes you no one
pays you guys don't pay and then so now
all these films get to not pay but
everyone else is paying I've even asked
people like looking someone else pay for
you I mean there's other countries other
people if someone you know and states or
LA or whatever you know offer discounts
something but you got it just it just
has to be the principle of you just
offering all these waivers of people and
we have to spend our time and resources
for staff to watch these films this
doesn't work for us I just I don't I
don't see it as being something that's
equitable or fair I know it's tough for
those kind of countries sanctions I
think that that's a tough situation but
for us we haven't really figured a way
to solve that you know this time quite
frankly and being honest I just you know
I know some other festivals do just
completely waive fees for for Iran and
things like that like feeling like okay
they can't pay any kind of stuff I just
it's something we feel like we can do
with our resources or our team size and
things I just
it's not something I just yeah so we
don't just not a poner that and many
times the emails if it's not with any
good effort or any good reason it's just
it is kind of it's yeah I look I
people always say right like you asked
for you got to ask right hey if you
don't ask you know receive like at least
ask throw it out there why not but if
you do submit then finally if you don't
have submitting so you're asking for a
waiver I'm gonna say no and then you
don't submit now your phone never plays
never gets in and then what's the point
of all that I think if you put that time
into doubt those emails like you put
your time at something else so that's
you know yeah well I mean I don't go
into you know I'm not gonna go into the
local coffee shop and say hey could you
just give me this one yeah exactly
latte for free this time is that you
know this to me it's there's nothing
different I don't even see how there is
someone how they can look at it it's any
different I don't and it's yeah that's
exactly a good point it's good analogy
it's like they're not gonna walk into
some store and say hey give it to me
free to speak just because right whether
we have struggle oh now everyone has
some struggle I mean how again it was in
a position of real struggle in college
and it was you found things away I did
you know you do what you got to do to
survive and get by and stuff you don't
just like ask for things just because
you feel you're in a different place or
especially what else are you you don't
have to pay just because you don't want
to right so those kind of you be like I
just don't understand like you're just
basically telling me you just don't feel
like paying so you're gonna ask it's
it's really odd to me if you think about
any other business like if people just
all with the Starbucks and they had ten
people a day coming in asking for free
cup of coffee it's not happening and
imagine if it was like you're like no
and you know I I just yeah it's really a
bizarre thing I guess it's just
something that is as part of this
business and it's a it's it's an
inherent with it but it's definitely
different and unique to this because
again like you said you're not Starbucks
is getting bombarded with free offers
every day for you know customers just
say hey look I want this one free this
time you know or okay just it's just I
don't know it's it's a yeah but it
definitely is a definitely peppy for
many programmers and festivals I own
imagine them speaking for others maybe
some don't care as much or like it or I
don't know but I would say most most
don't like it and are not appreciative
of that email all the time spent on that
so definitely yeah
yeah I'd say just don't
[Laughter]